la séance est ouverte la conférence des
présidents adopté ce matin de nouvelles
consignes sanitaires à l'unanimité en
conséquence je vous invite à respecter
les règles de distanciation en laissant
au moins une place libre entre chacun
d'entre vous par ailleurs le port du
masque est désormais obligatoire en
permanence y compris lors des
interventions des orateurs en votre nom
à tous
je tiens à adresser les plus vives
félicitations de l'assemblée nationale
madame emmanuelle le charpentier co
lauréate du prix nobel de chimie 2020
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur boris vallot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre actuellement 200
vaccins sont développées dans le monde
sur la copie de 19,42 font l'objet
d'essais cliniques une dizaine de tests
à large échelle l'actualité américaine
s'est évidemment l'élection
présidentielle mais c'est aussi cette
course au vaccin qui laisse espérer au
mois de décembre que deux d'entre eux
soient disponibles permettant de
vacciner l'ensemble de la population
américaine d'ici le mois d'avril vous le
savez dans un contexte de mise sur le
marché à accélérer et simplifier la
confiance et la transparence sont
particulièrement nécessaires parce que
les risques de conflits d'intérêts où la
pression sur les agences du médicaments
sont très fortes et s'il arrive dié a
rendu public son ces lignes directrices
et les conditions de mise sur le marché
d'un vaccin ça n'est pas le cas de l'
agence européenne du médicament je
voudrais savoir si le gouvernement a
connaissance des conditions sur
lesquelles de ces lignes directrices
européennes
de la même manière la commission
européenne n'a pas rendu publics les
contrats qui la lie au laboratoire sur
le développement et la fourniture de
vaccins et ça pourrait évidemment être
intéressant de savoir dans un contexte
de ressources rares comment seront
traités tels est elle payée en
particulier le nôtre je voudrais savoir
si le gouvernement a connaissance de ces
contrats avec la radio ce tri
pharmaceutique et s'il peut les rendre
publiques
de la même manière la question des
modalités de distribution des vaccins
est posée est posée dans l'urgence le
gouvernement britannique a déjà rendu
publics les modalités de sa distribution
l'armée le national health service
seront mobilisés il a déjà indiqué que
30 millions de britanniques
c'est à dire la moitié de sa population
aurait accès au vaccin ce qui l'amènera
à cibler d'abord les plus de 65 ans les
plus vulnérables évidemment les
personnels de santé
qu'en est il de la france avez vous
établi votre stratégie vaccinale
êtes vous déjà engagées dans la
préparation de la distribution de ces
vaccins mais ce premier set ne savons
rien ou pas grand chose est ce que après
le fiasco des masques après les retards
des tests vous nous préparez la débâcle
des vaccins
si monsieur député la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur
monsieur boris vallot ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'en l'occurrence vous n'êtes
jamais en retard sur une polémique et je
vous en félicite c'est tout à votre
honneur et je pense que c'est à
l'honneur de la confiance nécessaire
dans notre pays alors nous faisons face
à une vague épidémique qui mobilise les
soignants et l'ensemble des français
chapeau chapeau pour la pertinence avec
laquelle vous avez terminé votre
question je le dis en sincérité monsieur
vélo on n'est jamais déçu
monsieur le député lorsque un vaccin
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît laissez laisser le ministre
répondre à la question de monsieur vélo
s'il vous plaît allez-y monsieur le
ministre et messieurs les députés la
question de monsieur vélo est importante
puisqu'elle porte sur les vaccins contre
le coronavirus s'il vous plaît je me
permette d'y répondre
d'abord vous dire que le principe de
vaccins comme pour tous les vaccins
c'est qu'il doit être à la fois efficace
et sûre nous proposerons un vaccin aux
français lorsqu un vaccin aura démontré
qu'il est efficace et sûr nous avons
commencé avec quatre pays à l'initiative
de la france de l'italie de l'allemagne
et des pays-bas à contractualiser un
pré-contrat avec un laboratoire anglais
pour une première commande de vaccins
qui pourrait être disponible dans les
prochains mois nous avons immédiatement
passé le relais à la commission
européenne qui a chargé un comité
indépendant avec des experts qui
viennent de différents pays et qui ne
sont pas parties prises avec les pays
débats des laboratoires en question et
qui contractualise des pré commandes
massives pour pouvoir couvrir la
population européenne
nous avons ajouté à la demande du
président de la république une clause
qui s'assure qu'il ya le bien public
mondial qui soit pris en compte pour
pouvoir demain en faire bénéficier les
pays les plus pauvres
monsieur députés une partie de votre
question porte sur le secret de la
recherche et de et du développement en
matière de politique vaccinale les
éléments que je n'ai pas encore en
connaissance puisque par définition
lorsqu'il ya des projets de recherche
industrielle les données auxquelles nous
avons accès sont les données qui seront
publiées pour nous permettre d'acheter
sécurité et en confiance ces vaccins
notamment la recherche publique
développer dans kde astrazeneca par
l'université au public d'oxford vous
dire également que pour les indications
populationnelle la haute autorité de
santé évidemment totalement mobilisé
pour déterminer mais oxydation qui sera
fonction de la nature et de l'efficacité
évidemment rassurez vous tout est
adaptable cieux antoine souligne
monsieur le premier ministre
dominique 45 ans philippe 30 ans on dans
le cadre de l'exercice de leurs
fonctions au sein de l'antenne pj de
cergy-pontoise était victime d'une
ignoble attaque d'une violence inouïe
en cet instant nous devons avoir une
pensée pour eux dont l'un luttent encore
pour la vie et dont le second a vu la
sienne bouleversé à jamais mais aussi à
leurs collègues de champigny sur marne
attaqué ce week-end de manière
intolérable et particulièrement violent
ainsi qu'à toutes celles et ceux exposés
quotidiennement dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions je voudrais qu ici on leur
rende hommage pour leur courage leur
sang froid et leur professionnalisme
jusqu'à quand allons-nous rester
impuissants devant ces attaques ignobles
nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter de
déclarations dommage de soutien et
d'autres formes de compassion nous nous
devons collectivement d'apporter des
réponses à ces situations intolérables
et de plus en plus fréquentes
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
en fonction depuis cent jours et en
matière de sécurité
on attend toujours des actes forts vous
ne pouvez plus seulement commenté cette
escalade de la violence mais pointé le
problème et proposer des solutions
s'il s'agit d'un problème de moyens
pourquoi ne pas utiliser une partie de
l'argent de la relance pour augmenter
davantage les effectifs de police et
leur protection
s'il s'agit d'un problème de cadre légal
et de riposte policière
pourquoi ne pas envisager l'autorité
autorisé les forces de l'ordre a
répliqué dans un cadre moins anxiogène
pour eux s'il s'agit d'un problème de
réponse pénale
pourquoi refuser vue de faire preuve de
fermeté en instaurant des peines
minimales en cas d'atteinte aux
policiers et en musclant ainsi l'arsenal
pénal
s'il s'agit d'un problème socio éducatif
pourquoi ne pas lancer un grand chantier
pour un culte pour inculquer aux jeunes
générations le respect des forces de
l'ordre mais de grâce monsieur le
premier ministre
ne restons pas là nous lamenter à
déplorer agissant de concert pour
rétablir l'ordre républicain
quand la république est attaquée la
république doit triompher
alors monsieur le premier ministre ma
question est simple que comptez vous
faire
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
savignat permettez moi évidemment de
m'associer à l'hommage que vous rendez
aux forces de l'ordre et singulièrement
aux deux policiers qui très sauvagement
ont été attaqués et qui selon toute
vraisemblance les actes qui ont été
commis contre on était pour leur causer
la mort je me suis rendu dans votre
département vous avez la gentillesse
d'ailleurs de me signaler
effectivement la solidarité en tant que
parlementaire du val d'oise c'est le cas
bien sûr de tous les parlementaires du
val d'oise
ici je le sais et j'ai été saluée l'un
des deux policiers qui pouvaient être
visible dès l'hôpital
edit l'ensemble du commissariat l
ensemble la police judiciaire du val
d'oise à quel point en effet cet acte
nous révulse est l' enquête est en cours
monsieur le député mais vous aurez
constaté que puisque la presse en a fait
état jeudi devant le garde des sceaux
que cette personne qui a été arrêté et
après de longues heures en garde à vue
et coups est présenté devant un
magistrat instructeur d'autres d'autres
actes du travail sous l'autorité du
procureur de la république sont en ce
moment même où dans les heures qui
viennent en train d'être fait je ne
permettrai pas de commenter mais
évidemment aucun acte restera impuni sur
le fond de votre question monsieur
députés faut-il des moyens la réponse
est oui
votez le plf présenté par bruno le maire
est liée du soft 40% d'augmentation des
crédits du ministère de l'intérieur
votez monsieur le député
le projet de loi de finances pour la
première fois en trois ans c'est bien
cette majorité qui crée 10000 postes de
policiers et de gendarmes voter monsieur
le député le plan de relance puisqu'un
quart des véhicules seront changés
lorsqu'il était encore quelques années
c'était un véhicule tous les huit ans
qui a été changée beauté monsieur le
député les armements pelleve que vous
n'avez pas voté qui permet de faire plus
de trois mille opérations avant le 31
décembre les commissariats en toute
chose évitons les polémiques et votons
monsieur le député merci monsieur lemay
avant avant de lui donner la parole je
suis heureux de souhaiter la bienvenue à
madame muriel rock etienne devenu député
de la première circonscription du tarn
le 8 octobre dernier en remplacement de
monsieur philippe folliot chers
collègues vous avez la parole
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
c'est avec une émotion certaine que je
prends la parole pour la première fois
dans cet hémicycle
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
ministre
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
notre pays se prépare à affronter à ce
que beaucoup appellent déjà la deuxième
vague de l'épidémie de lakovic 19 en
effet durant l'été le gouvernement
amplifier la capacité de notre pays en
test et a fortement encouragé voire
selon les territoires
généraliser le port du masque en
intérieur comme en extérieur
de plus une stratégie de concertation
avec les élus locaux a été mise en
oeuvre afin de prendre les décisions au
plus près du terrain sous l'impulsion du
couple maires préfets si certaines
difficultés on peut parfois apparaître
nous savons que le gouvernement et
l'ensemble des services de l'état sont
mobilisés pour lutter contre le virus et
protéger nos concitoyens
j'ai pu m'en rendre compte dans le tarn
et je souhaiterais notamment remercié
les services de la préfecture mais aussi
l'ensemble des élus locaux pour leur
action mais aujourd'hui malgré tous les
efforts des françaises et des français
qui nous faut saluer la situation se
dégrade
pour faire face un suivi actif de
l'épidémie est quotidiennement
effectuées sur l'ensemble du territoire
et des mesures de restriction concertée
et adaptés sont prises localement le
plan renforcé a été déclenchée depuis
septembre dans les hôpitaux d'un certain
nombre de départements les plus touchés
par la reprise épidémique
nos médecins et soignants sont
pleinement mobilisés nous devons
solennellement rendre hommage à leur
engagement dans ce cadre suite au
conseil de défense tenue ce matin et à
la veille de la prise de parole du
président de la république pourriez vous
monsieur le ministre nous faire un point
sur la situation sanitaire
et nous dire comment notre stratégie
pourrait évoluer je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et madame la députée rock
etienne tout d'abord bienvenue au
parlement je vous remercie pour votre
question qui permet de faire
effectivement un point rapide sur
l'évolution épidémique dans notre pays
d'abord vous dire que hélas l'épidémie
continue son ascension
elle touchait vous souvenez vers la fin
de l'été essentiellement les populations
jeunes avec un impact sanitaire qui
était faible
et puis les populations jeunes le virus
est passé aux populations moins jeunes
et notamment les populations vulnérables
âgées fragiles avec des ce qu'on appelle
des comorbidités et l'impact sanitaire a
commencé ce que nous voyons est ce que
nous disent les soignants dans les
hôpitaux
c'est que cette vague hospitalière qui a
commencé inquiète fragilise notre
édifice à lithaire est qu'il nous faut
prendre des mesures partout où c'est
nécessaire pour faire face à cette
épidémie redoutable madame la députée ce
n'est pas un cas franco-français
l'espagne la belgique les pays bas font
face à une épidémie forte l'italie et
l'allemagne ont observé depuis
maintenant plus d'une semaine et ainsi
que les pays d'europe de l'est
une ascension épidémique assez
importante assez importante qui oblige
chacun des pays à prendre des mesures
avec une stratégie d'ailleurs qui est
calqué en tout cas qui est parallèle à
notre stratégie
je le rappelle tester tracé protéger
protéger les populations vulnérables
appliqués les gestes barrière aérer son
domicile et les pièces dans lesquelles
on se trouve
et puis partout où c'est nécessaire des
mesures de freinage adapter la situation
épidémique propres à chaque territoire
vous l'avez dit manable à la députée
consulter avec les élus et les
représentants de l'état dans les
territoires de manière à freiner la
diffusion du virus
je crois que les français ont
entraînement pleinement pris conscience
de la gravité de la situation épidémique
qu'ils sont parfaitement mobilisés pour
faire face aux côtés de l'état à ce
virus qui a causé des dégâts
considérables de notre pays et que nous
devons arrêter au plus vite afin
d'éviter que ces dégâts hospitaliers
notamment deux deviennent trop
importants
c'est l'objet des décisions qui sont
prises par le premier ministre et le
président de la république en conseil de
défense et sur lesquels le prix dans
leur la république aura à se prononcer
demain soir vous l'avais dit je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur olivier falorni
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de la transition écologique
vous nous avez manqué la semaine
dernière lors du débat parlementaire sur
le projet de loi réintroduisant les
néonicotinoïdes ce véritable poison pour
l'environnement en effet j'aurais tant
aimé entendre à nouveau la secrétaire
d'état à la biodiversité de l'époque qui
ici même en 2016 disait nous disait avec
justesse je la cite donc je vous cite
quoi qu'il arrive en 2020 c'est fini
pour tous les néo de haute nicotine aux
ide
on sait très bien que des dérogations
c'est la porte ouverte à ce qu'il ne
soit jamais interdit nous sommes en 2020
et la boîte de pandore est à nouveau
ouverte
idem pour le glyphosate classé
cancérogène probable par l' oms autres
poisons dont le président de la
république le 27 novembre 2017
prométhée qu'il serait interdit au moins
dans trois ans sauf que dans trois ans
c'est maintenant est aussi l'heureux le
reniement le renoncement c'est
maintenant et que dire des engagements
pris par le chef de l'état devant la
convention citoyenne pour le climat en
juin aujourd'hui les propositions de
cette convention tombent comme à
gravelotte
alors madame la ministre je sais combien
il est difficile de résister face aux
lobbys mais quand on prend quand on fait
des promesses on doit tenir bon pour les
tenir
vous savez andré j10
et andré gide disait la promesse de la
chenille n'engage pas le papillon alors
je vous invite si j'ose dire à être en
même temps la chine et le papillon la
parole à monsieur julien de normandie
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député falorni
est ce que monsieur le député un jour
vous pourrez arrêter d'opposer
agriculture à environnement cela ne fait
aucun sens cesser d'opposer
l'agriculture à l'environnement cesser
d'opposer les uns avec les autres
accepter qu'on travaille de concert la
ministre de l'écologie et moyennes vous
savez monsieur falorni un agriculteur sa
vie de la terre sa chérie le seul sa vie
de l'environnement sa chérie
l'environnement les agriculteurs
monsieur le député il était écologiste
avant même que vous ne deveniez
écologistes elle est là la réalité
alors arrêtez arrêtez de les opposer
cela ne fait aucun sens et monsieur le
député s'agissant du glyphosate la
position avec faire la transition elle
est là au moment où je vous parle c'est
un tiers des agriculteurs qui ont déjà
arrêté le glyphosate la semaine dernière
avec la ministre de l'écologie on a pris
les éléments de l'anp 16 qui montre à
quel point aujourd'hui la transition
elle se fait et elle est là l engagement
du président de la république monsieur
le député il est très clair il y aura un
arrêt du glyphosate dès lors qu'il n'ya
pas d'alternative crédible pour le faire
elle est là la position pragmatique elle
est là l'écologie de terrains l'écologie
des territoires l'écologie est réel et
pas l'écologie de l'incantation
mais ça ça ne vous plaît pas alors c'est
ça la réalité
et puis vous savez monsieur falorni vous
adorez vous adorez les citations vous
adorez les idées moi je vais vous
soumettre en question une question ô
combien difficile
il ya toute une génération
d'agriculteurs monsieur le député toute
une génération qui ont été accompagnés
et élevé dans ce qu'on appelle
l'agriculture de conservation et
dites-le à vos administrés que grâce aux
agriculteurs aujourd'hui
kft le carbone dans le sol on empêche
les effets des gaz à effet de serre et
ça monsieur le député saad nécessite des
désherbants jours on aura trouvé une
solution pour empêcher la collision
d'objectifs écologique on aura fait une
grande avancée est saisonnière si
monsieur lui la parole
et comme eux la parole est un monsieur
dimitri houbron merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la justice monsieur le
ministre
comme vous l'avait déjà souligné nos
concitoyens ont aujourd'hui peur et
manque de confiance dans la capacité de
notre institution judiciaire à apporter
une réponse adaptée à la situation telle
qu'il la vie vous l'aperçoivent trop
lente peu efficace laxistes voici hélas
les qualificatifs notre justice pour les
français je tiens à saluer votre
détermination à obtenir une hausse
historique du budget de la justice de 8%
ainsi notre justice développera demain
une branche de proximité forte de 200
millions d'euros
vous avez annoncé par exemple le
recrutement de 764 renfort de greef
juris assistant d'ici quelques mois des
professions essentiel que je connais
bien pour les avoir exercé avant de
siéger ici qui soutiennent
quotidiennement les magistrats dans leur
mission
monsieur le ministre vous disposerez
demain de moyens et d'un volontarisme
pour corriger la faiblesse mortifère de
notre justice à savoir l'engorgement des
tribunaux qui hélas fait passer sous le
radar
cette petite délinquance ces petits
délits qui pourrissent la vie des
français il faut stopper ce sentiment
d'impunité qui exaspère jusqu'à nos
forces de l'ordre le groupe agir
ensemble portera en novembre une
proposition de loi visant à améliorer la
justice pénale de proximité grâce
notamment aux alternatives aux
poursuites
au lieu de s'engager dans une procédure
longue et fastidieuse le procureur
pourrait exiger du délinquant qu ils
repeignent le commissariat qui l'attaqué
ils pourraient aussi exiger de verser
une contribution dite citoyenne à une
association d'aidé aux victimes qui
oeuvre tant pour nos concitoyens
c'est ça
ans pénale claire rapide efficace et
comprise par nos concitoyens
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
préciser les prochaines circulaire qui
seront édictées pour guider et
simplifier le travail des acteurs de la
justice et nous dévoiler les détails
complémentaires sur votre vision de la
justice de proximité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député ou buscher dimitri
d'abord je ne laisserai jamais dire que
la justice de notre pays est laxiste et
je rappelle qu'en matière criminelle
c'est le peuple français qui rend la
justice
première remarque deuxième remarque dès
mon arrivée j'ai ouvrait pour mettre en
oeuvre la justice de proximité
j'ai obtenu un budget exceptionnel qu il
vous appartiendra de voter et vous le
ferez sans aucun doute un budget à la
hauteur des enjeux
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
député cela se traduit concrètement par
des recrutements massifs 2450 personnel
supplémentaire dont 750 contractuels
dans les jours qui viennent et qui sont
en passe déjà d'être recruté
c'est la preuve fondamental de
l'attachement que je porte à la justice
pour répondre à votre question
d'ores et déjà j'ai pris une circulaire
de politique pénale le 1er octobre j'ai
rencontré les procureurs généraux
il est question en effet de justice
rapide systématique et n'en déplaise à
certin proportionnée bien évidemment
cette justice elle a pour effet de
rendre immédiatement une décision contre
les petits délinquants qui pourrissent
la vie des gens les rodéos les tags les
incivilités devenu absolument
insupportable je souhaite également que
plus d'audience pénales et civiles se
tiennent à l'extérieur des tribunaux
dans une justice de proximité une
justice foraine fait pour les plus
défavorisés de nos concitoyens
parce que cette proximité ne peut se
faire sans les élus locaux
j'ai demandé au procureur de se
rapprocher des élus pour qu'ensemble ils
partagent leurs expériences et soient
plus efficaces
je sais pouvoir compter sur votre
engagement et sur celui de toute la
majorité bien évidemment pour compléter
mon action dans le domaine législatif
votre proposition de loi monsieur le
député en témoigne merci à monsieur
l'accélération notamment par l'exécution
des athlètes à monsieur du berger j'ai
le plaisir de donner la parole à notre
collègue jean-luc riser qui reprend sa
place parmi nous ce dont je me réjouis
très sincèrement est très amicalement
merci mes chers collègues
merci je suis très touché
eh bien monsieur le premier ministre les
chers collègues c'est bien sûr avec
émotion chacun le comprendra que je
m'adresse à vous aujourd'hui admis le 4
mars dernier
plongé dans le coma durant quatre
semaines
et bien après deux mois et demi
d'hospitalisation j'ai pu quitter
l'hôpital emile muller de mulhouse à
vous monsieur le président à tous les
collègues issus de tous les bancs de
notre assemblée
j'exprime ma reconnaissance pour leurs
messages de soutien et de sympathie
hommage aussi et surtout à tous les
soignants qui ont sauvé tant de vies et
qui mérite les applaudissements
malheureusement malheureusement tout le
monde n'a pas eu la chance de battre ce
sacré virus d'alors chez reconnaît
qu'elle est notre devoir sacré il est de
tirer les leçons de cette épreuve
collective
trop de dysfonctionnements sont apparus
j'en suis le témoin vivant depuis des
années je me bats et roselyne bachelot
s'en souvient contre le déclassement des
hôpitaux de proximité
monsieur le premier ministre pouvait
vous vous engagez à ne plus fermer deux
lits ni de service si indispensable dans
deux hôpitaux
depuis des années nous nous battons
contre la sur administration de nos
services de santé animé d'une seule
logique comptable
allez-vous lancer une réflexion
concertée avec les élus sur le rôle et
sur les missions des ars
depuis des années nous nous battons pour
que le travail des soignants soit
revalorisé le 1er milices des mesures
ont été prises mais allez vous corriger
les injustices et les oublis vis-à-vis
de nombreuses catégories de soignants
générés par le ségur de la santé et les
inégalités dans le versement des primes
qu'ovide le premier ministe l'heure est
grave
votre désir de proximité et reconnu
allez vous redonnez humanité cohérence
lisibilité aux mesures qui ont été
prises
allez vous créer ce choc de confiance et
ce choc d'espeyran
tant attendu par le soignant et par nos
concitoyens
il y va des valeurs de la république il
y va de la grandeur et de l'honneur de
la france et pour tous ceux qui se
battent aujourd'hui contre le virus
je n'ai qu'un message à leurs données il
va cran ce virus et vive la vie merci
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés cher jean luc
reitzer quel plaisir de vous revoir ici
aujourd'hui
quel plaisir vous êtes la preuve vivante
malheureusement que ce virus touche tout
le monde
tout le monde et que personne ne peut
être épargné ni à l'abri de ces dégâts
encore aujourd'hui dans la deuxième
vague mesdames et messieurs les députés
nous observons nous observons un
rajeunissement dans les hospitalisations
réanimation nous savons nous savons
qu'au delà des décès qui ont dû être
comptabilisées au delà des décès qu'en
dû être comptabilisé la maladie laisse
des séquelles très importante
c'est donc effectivement monsieur le
député une mobilisation générale qui est
absolument nécessaire
nous avons tiré les conséquences et très
rapidement de la première vague
j'ai signé le 13 juillet dernier le
ségur de la santé qui vous en
conviendrez surtout les bas est un
tournant historique dans le pilotage et
les moyens affectés à notre système de
soins je suis sûr d'ailleurs je suis sûr
d'ailleurs que vous voterez le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui traduit en moyens pour nos
personnels soignants qui traduit ainsi
qu'avec le plan de relance du projet de
loi de finances la reprise la dette
hospital
r le maintien des hôpitaux de proximité
et un volume conséquent
d'investissements de modernisation la
difficulté devant laquelle nous nous
trouvons et je le lis trop souvent c'est
qu'effectivement ces augmentations de
rémunérations que nous allons je vous
l'annoncé seuil et d'accélérer première
tranche en octobre plus de 90 euros la
prochaine tranche est prévue en mars
il faudra que nous accélérions les
versements pour marquer la
reconnaissance aux professionnels de
santé et je salue notamment ceux de
mulhouse
monsieur le député qui ont été comme
tous les autres si exemplaire pendant la
première vague de la pandémie
mais mesdames et sur les députés de
grâce ne faisons pas croire alors que la
deuxième vague est là qu on peut
recruter des anesthésistes réanimateurs
où les former en trois mois
pas plus qu'une infirmière évidemment
les mesures que nous avons prises
provoqueront des résultats sur le long
terme nous devons muscler le dispositif
sur toutes les heures supplémentaires et
l'attractivité immédiate
croyez en la mobilisation totale du
gouvernement non seulement pour faire
face à la deuxième vague qui s'annonce
par des mesures de prévention
fusse-t-elle strictes que nous
approuverons tous que par des mesures
structurelles pour doper renforcer le
système sanitaire français qui le mérite
amplement
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur bruno duvergé
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances depuis
septembre nous avait présenté un plan de
relance pour accélérer la reprise de
l'activité économique et amortir les
conséquences sociales de la crise liée
au coït 19
ce plan de relance doit amplifier la
transition énergétique
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi 30 milliards
d'euros de ce plan est consacré à cet
objectif
c'est également la raison pour laquelle
nous avons nous vous avons alerté lors
de l'examen du plf sur des dispositions
qui nous semblait entier écologique et
antisociales comme la taxation de
l'essence sans plomb 95 e10 cette hausse
de 1 centime par litre aurait eu pour
effet d'augmenter le plein de super de
30 centimes en 2021 60 centimes en 2022
c'est pourquoi suite aux annonces que
l'élu ce matin dans les médias je vous
demande monsieur le ministre de bien
vouloir confirmer devant la
représentation nationale l'abandon de
cette taxe qui pénaliserait nos
concitoyens pour un bénéfice et que
écologique quasi nul
il reste cependant deux sujets sur
lesquels je souhaitais attirer votre
attention
d'abord la réforme du système
d'indemnités kilométriques en fonction
de la puissance des véhicules et ensuite
la taxation sur le point des véhicules
ces deux mesures pourraient avoir pour
effet de désavantager certaines familles
en zone rurale mais surtout d'annuler le
bénéfice de certaines évolutions
technologiques conçu par le constructeur
automobile
la taxation des technologies a toujours
pour effet d'être un frein à la
recherche et à l'innovation
il vaut toujours mieux taxer directement
l'objectif à atteindre que les moyens de
l'atteindre
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre à
l'occasion de l'examen d'appels est très
sensible je souhaiterais vous ne puisse
que vous puissiez répondre à ces trois
sujets je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur olivier dussopt de ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
du verger vous interroger le
gouvernement sur la fiscalité écologique
sur la poursuite d'une trajectoire qui
vise à construire une fiscalité plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et qui
accompagne l'économie sur cette
trajectoire transition vous avez
souligné que le projet de loi de
finances que nous vous présentons avec
que bono le maire présente et porte un
certain nombre de dispositions qui ont
comme objectif de toujours participé à
cette construction d'une fiscalité
écologique
les mesures allant dans ce sens sont
nombreuses beaucoup font consensus et je
m'en réjouis puisque cela démontre aussi
notre capacité collective à construire
ce nouveau modèle vous avez loupé une
mesure en particulier la mesure qui vise
à une convergence de la fiscalité
autant de centimes par litre entre
différents composantes de carburant le 5
et le 10 et qu'il y aurait
qui se serait traduit par une
augmentation de deux centimes d'euro du
litre de sans plomb 95
comme vous l'avez noté et parce que nous
avons entendu les réactions les
inquiétudes et les interrogations de
très nombreux parlementaires dont vous
êtes nous avons annoncé ce matin avec
bono maire que nous donnerions un avis
favorable aux amendements parlementaires
visant à revenir sur cette disposition
et nous veillerons à ce que la fiscalité
sur le carburant soit parfaitement
inchangé dans le plf 2021 de madonna de
manière à répondre pleinement à votre
attente au delà de slide un certain
nombre de propositions qui sont portées
aujourd'hui par la convention citoyenne
elles nourrissent le débat comme
l'indiqué le président de la république
il y a lieu parfois d'en regarder les
modalités d'examiner leur temporalité de
veiller à ce que les conditions de mise
en oeuvre soit les mêmes ou en tout cas
réfléchir à l'aune de l'actualité et de
la nature de la crise que nous
traversons
mais nous devons continuer à construire
à échanger sur ce sujet là
cela ne doit pas nous faire oublier ce
que vous avez soumis au début de votre
question ce projet de loi de finances
est historique pour la transition
écologique
nous augmentons le budget du ministère
la transition écologique de presque 1
milliard d'euros et en plus de cette
augmentation
nous consacrons un tiers du plan de
relance un divertissement c'est plus de
30 milliards d'euros qui sont consacrés
la transition écologique c'est là le
principal outil d verdissement de toute
notre économie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur stéphane peu merci monsieur le
président cette question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre la semaine
dernière nous avons appris en même temps
si j'ose dire de france stratégie d'une
part que l'effet combiné de vos
décisions sur l'allégement fiscal des
dividendes et la suppression de l'sf ont
fait littéralement exploser les revenus
des plus riches et du secours populaire
d'autre part la même semaine que depuis
le début de la crise du coc vide
un million de personnes supplémentaires
ont vu leur vie basculer dans la
pauvreté
désormais dans la sixième puissance
économique du monde 10 millions de nos
compatriotes dépendent des banques
alimentaires ne savent plus comment
payer leur loyer l'eau et l'électricité
renoncent aux soins et vivent la peur au
ventre
ces nouveaux captif de la pauvreté sont
des intérimaires des extras des
personnes en fin de cdd saisonniers et
des chômeurs en fin de droits qui ne
bénéficient pas ou plus de la couverture
chômage aux raisons de votre réforme ce
sont également des indépendants des
commerçants artisans auto-entrepreneurs
et ce sont aussi des étudiants et des
jeunes qui n'ont droit ni au rsa ni au
chômage et dont les premiers pas dans la
vie se feront sur un chemin dans gouin
bref ce sont les premiers de corvée et
les cobayes de la start up nation
monsieur le premier ministre pour faire
face à cette vague de pauvreté inédite
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
pouvez-vous à défaut de vous réinventer
au moins de vous amendé et tirer les
enseignements de vos erreurs alors que
notre pays traverse une crise
exceptionnelle
allez-vous vous corriger et mettre la
justice sociale au coeur de votre plan
de relance allez-vous mettre enfin à
contribution l'enrichissement
exceptionnelle de quelques-uns par un
impôt exceptionnel un appeau qu'ovide au
bénéfice de tous merci chers collègues
la parole à monsieur olivier la parole à
monsieur olivier dussopt ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
député monsieur le député peu lorsque ce
gouvernement a pris cette fonction est
que lorsque cette majorité a pris ses
fonctions il venait se passer deux
quinquennats qu'ils avaient été tous les
deux caractérisée par le même mouvement
c'est l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires et en particulier sur les
ménages même s'il y avait une inflexion
pour les entreprises avec la mise en
place du cic eux au milieu du
quinquennat précédent
la ligne de ce gouvernement est
différente
il s'agit de baisser les impôts et nous
baissons les impôts comme nous ne les
avons jamais baissé à la fin de l'année
2021 la baisse d'impôt aura atteint 45
milliards d'euros la moitié pour les
entreprises la moitié pour les ménages
et lorsqu'on parle de la baisse des
ménages qui dépassent les 20 milliards
d'euros
il s'agit de 10 milliards d'euros pour
la taxe d'habitation de 80% des français
bien loin des 0,1 pour cent vous
stigmatisez il s'agit de l'exonération
de fiscalité du cotisations sociales sur
les heures supplémentaires dont on sait
pertinemment ce sont les ouvriers les
employés les classes moyennes qui en
font le plus il s'agit de la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu sur les deux
premières tranches pour 5 milliards
d'euros et c'est aussi ce gouvernement
qui avec ses bases d'un pur ou en plus
de ces baisses d'impôts a mis en place
la plus grande revalorisation des minima
sociaux a mis en place le reste à charge
c'est grâce à ce gouvernement que si
vous avez besoin de changer de lunettes
si vous avez besoin de soins dentaires
si vous avez besoin de prothèses
auditives vous aurez un reste à charge
des ronds et vous deviez vous en
féliciter
c'est ce gouvernement c'est ce
gouvernement qui fait preuve de la plus
grande solidarité vis-à-vis des plus
fragiles et qui contrairement à vous
s'attaque aux inégalités à la racine
plutôt de se contenter d'en traiter les
symptômes
c'est cette majorité qui a de quoi être
fier kiev de ce qu'elle fait bien de ce
que nous faisons et je vous le dis
monsieur peu les leçons solidarité nous
n'avons pas besoin merci monsieur le
ministre la parole et à madame monsieur
sillery lac
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur mercredi dernier
à ernée sur scène dans la
circonscription
deux policiers ont fait face à un
déferlement de violence inouïe nos
forces de l'ordre ont font
malheureusement de plus en plus la cible
comme à champigny sur marne le week-end
dernier les policiers ont été tabassés
matraque et se sont fait tirer dessus à
bout portant à plusieurs reprises disons
le il y a eu volonté d'en finir
j'ai une pensée particulière pour ses
deux policiers dominique et philippe de
la police judiciaire de cergy victime
d'une tentative d'homicide
au cours de la fonction à 45 et 30 ans
ce sont leurs carrières et leurs vies
qui sont brisées
je voudrais ici devant la représentation
nationale leur adresser mes plus
sincères voeux de prompt rétablissement
et exprimé à leur collègue
mon indignation notre indignation face à
cet acte inqualifiable
je souhaite réaffirmer notre
indéfectible soutien dont l'engagement
sans faille des forces de l'ordre de
sécurité au service de la population
dans le val d'oise tentes partout
ailleurs dans le pays les policiers les
gendarmes mais aussi les
sapeurs-pompiers exerce des missions de
plus en plus difficile restez calme en
toutes circonstances porter assistance
et secours protéger ou encore
appréhender les malfaiteurs aujourd'hui
tout cela les expose à un risque
permanent actu par le simple fait qu'ils
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
ou qu'ils portent un uniforme cette
violence gratuite à l'égard de nos
forces de l'ordre comme à l'encontre de
nos concitoyens n'est plus acceptable
monsieur le ministre je connais votre
mobilisation sur le sujet de la sécurité
nous attendons une réponse pénale ferme
c'est indispensable pour que la défiance
à l'égard de la justice se transforme en
confiance alors ma question est simple
quelles mesures allez vous prendre pour
que nous puissions dire à nos
concitoyens
plus jamais ça je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole à monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés même la députée
risac pardonnez moi une nouvelle fois de
redire je les dis devant vous dans ce
département du val d'oise lors de mon
déplacement je lui ai dit en réponse à
votre collègue toute la solidarité
évidemment du gouvernement et à quel
point on s'associe aux mots que vous
avez tenus pour protéger les policiers
les gendarmes les sapeurs pompiers les
élus tous ceux qui sont des magistrats
tout ce qu'ils sont dépositaires de
l'autorité publique
vous aurez dans quelques jours madame la
députée l'occasion de débattre dans cet
hémicycle de la proposition de loi de
vos collègues même thuriau et monsieur
fauvergue j'espère d'ailleurs que tous
indépendamment de la majorité
soutiendront ce texte de bon sens qui
remet de l'autorité qui est bien sûr
avec les maires ce qu'on appelle le
quotidien de sécurité qui protège nos
forces de l'ordre
elle le protège notamment parce que ne
doivent pas être la cible de ce qu'on a
trop laissé faire notamment la cible sur
les réseaux sociaux ou la cible
effectivement aux télévisions on a vu
des images avec des policiers qui se
font agresser en dehors de leur lieu de
travail elle les protège aussi comme les
pompiers puisque le congrès des sapeurs
pompiers a lieu ce vendredi et ce samedi
le président de république aura
l'occasion de s'exprimer devant eux
les forces de l'ordre et les pompiers
qui doivent être davantage protégés
notamment en équipant davantage de
caméras de vidéoprotection sur ces sur
leurs véhicules afin de permettre aux
magistrats de mieux condamner encore
plus qu'ils auront davantage
effectivement de faits incontestables à
ce que vous savez que souvent
malheureusement là où il ya des
difficultés c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'éléments comme des déviants de
vidéosurveillance et vous aurez
l'occasion aussi on s'en doute d'écouter
le président de la république à la
sortie peut être les expressions que
prendront les syndicats de police
puisqu'il recevra fait exceptionnel
jeudi matin avec moi même avec le garde
des sceaux avec le directeur général de
la police nationale et préfet de police
pour écouter les syndicats de police que
je vais d'ailleurs écoutez moi même tout
l'après midi
ce ce ce jour et vous dire que la loi de
finances que vous allez voter une
nouvelle fois donnera les moyens en plus
de moyens juridiques des deux forces de
l'ordre merci madame pour tout ce que
vous faites avec la majorité
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame marie-christine dalloz
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
vous êtes en poste à matignon depuis
depuis cent jours et la réalité c'est
que vous augmentez déjà les taxes des
français je veux parler du durcissement
sans précédent du malus écologique sur
l'automobile prévus dans le budget pour
en effet l'achat d'un véhicule neuf sera
considérablement alourdie par ce malus
dès le 1er janvier
à l'origine le malus avait été créé pour
financer les bonus dans une demain dans
une démarche et incitatives mais vous
monsieur le premier ministre vous casser
cette logique en augmentant beaucoup
plus fortement le malus que le bonus
l'an prochain le malus va rapporter 500
millions de plus à l'état que le coût du
bonus automobile dans les fêtes vous
allez multiplié par quatre en un an et
par huit en deux ans le montant du malus
pour un véhicule émettant 138 grammes de
co2 et il en va ainsi des il va ainsi
des voitures familiales comme la peugeot
3008 ou encore la dacia sandero de
nombreux modèles populaires seront
inaccessibles pour répondre aux besoins
quotidiens et professionnels des
familles les territoires ruraux et les
familles les plus modestes seront les
premiers à souffrir de vos choix
budgétaires notre usage de la voiture
est déterminé en fonction de notre lieu
d'habitation et de l'offre de services
de transport bien souvent inexistantes
transports publics est souvent
inexistante dans nos territoires et
notamment en montagne c'est bien là
l'exemple frappant d'une écologie
exclusivement punitive servant surtout
de prétexte pour faire la proche de nos
concitoyens
cette politique budgétaire est non
seulement injuste et touchera
directement au portefeuille des ménages
mais elle a également suicidaire pour
les fleurons industriels français de
l'automobile gravement impacté notre
mettant en péril des milliers d'emplois
le en même temps a ses limites et
s'avère même dangereux monsieur le
premier ministre
à l'heure de votre premier bilan n'est
ce pas particulièrement incohérent avec
la politique de relance que vous dites
vouloir mettre en
merci je reconnais avec la parole à
monsieur olivier du soft ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée dalloz vous terminez votre
question en interrogeant sur la
cohérence ou ou l'incohérence il ya une
grande cohérence à la politique qui vous
émeut proposées en matière fiscale
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure en réponse
au député du verger nous menons une
politique de transition
nous nous voulons construire la première
économie décarbonée nous voulons
accompagner la production et la
consommation sur le chemin de la
transition écologique et nous avons
effectivement retenu dans le projet de
loi de finances
une mesure qui consiste à augmenter le
malus en fonction de l'émission des gaz
à effet de serre et particulièrement
d'ici au 2 avec une mise en oeuvre
progressive et l'atteinte d'un palier
qui correspond à un palier encore
supérieurs à la moyenne des véhicules
produits en france sle cette volonté que
nous poursuivons et cette volonté que
nous mettons en oeuvre à travers cette
politique fiscale
il s'agit pas de chercher une recette
supplémentaire
il s'agit de mettre en place des outils
fiscaux incitatifs pour accompagner la
conversion des parcs automobiles
vous avez beaucoup insisté sur cette
question du malus
vous auriez pu aussi souligné dans le
même temps les efforts que le
gouvernement fait pour favoriser la
conversion du parc automobile avec des
primes à la conversion qui atteignent un
montant que vous n'avez jamais connu
avec la volonté d'accompagner les
consommateurs et les ménages français à
la fois sur la conversion automobile
mais aussi sur la rénovation énergétique
des logements sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments publics
tout se tient en termes de cohérence et
je le répète nous construisons un chemin
de transition écologique et
environnemental appuyé sur des outils
fiscaux en veillant au pouvoir d'achat
des français et sans jamais remettre en
cause la trajectoire de baisse des
prélèvements obligatoires que j'ai
rappelé et qui se traduit par une baisse
d'impôt de 45 milliards d'euros pour les
ménages et les entreprises françaises
c'est là notre objectif c'est un clic de
crête et joseph et à nous suivre sur ce
chemin merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et hamada madi chapelier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la santé et des
solidarités
après les épuisants mois du confinement
où ils ont été acclamés comme des héros
les soignants ont beaucoup espéré du
ségur de la santé pense à obtenir une
véritable reconnaissance de la valeur de
leur travail
ces espoirs ont été douchés
de nombreuses professions sont amers
sages-femmes libéraux santé de ville
médico sociaux pour ne citer qu'eux ils
sont nombreux à estimer ne pas avoir été
entendu la place prépondérante est
laissée aux administrations dans les
négociations alors que presque partout
elles ont été perçues comme un frein ne
passe pas la fuite du public vers le
privé se poursuit chez les soignants
menant à une aggravation des conditions
de travail pour ceux qui restent et pire
selon un dernier sondage fournis par
lord infirmiers 43 % des infirmiers
envisage d'exercer une autre profession
que la leur alors que près de trente
quatre mille postes seraient vacants les
soignants sont à bout mais on leur
demande d'être mobilisés face à cette
seconde vague alors que les malades de
la coved reflux à nouveau vers les
hôpitaux
le sentiment est que rien n'a vraiment
changé monsieur le ministre ne serait-il
pas temps de donner la priorité à une
véritable et profonde de réforme de
notre système de santé en tenant compte
et en écoutant réellement ces femmes ces
hommes ces professionnels qui font notre
système de santé
merci madame la députée de paris la
parole que monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
madame la députée moi je suis très fier
que cette majorité et ce gouvernement
augmente les salaires de plus d'un
million et demi de soignants pour plus
de 8 8 milliards d'euros par an madame n
est plus qu en terme de bilan pour
chercher surtout les bons vous ne
trouverez jamais une telle
revalorisation jamais 15% d'augmentation
des salaires pour des aides soignantes
pour des infirmières pour des
brancardiers qui travaille au samu aux
urgences en ehpad à l'hôpital
la plus forte réduction des écarts de
rémunération entre hommes et femmes de
notre pays de toute l'histoire parce que
85 % des bénéficiaires sont des femmes
madame la députée on peut quitter les
bancs de la majorité on peut être
critique mais pas avoir des oeillères
regardez ce que vous allez être amenés à
voter dans le cadre du plfss 225 euros
de rémunération de salaires nets par
mois de plus quoi qu'il arrive pour plus
d'un million et demi de salariés
ça n'est jamais arrivé dans aucun
secteur de notre pays auparavant
je ne dis pas que c'est trop je ne dis
pas que ça suffirait restaurer
l'attractivité
mais par pitié par pitié quand on parle
attractivité
activités des carrières essayons aussi
de promouvoir ce qui a été fait de bien
madame la députée on s'arrête pas aux
salaires il y avait changement de
gouvernance on sort de la tarification à
l'activité
on change totalement la place des
soignants la démocratie interne des
établissements échanges et 6 milliards
d'euros d'investissements pour l'hôpital
et les ehpad 13 milliards d'euros de
reprise de la dette des hôpitaux pour la
première fois vous avez un gouvernement
qui dit nous n'allons pas fermer des
lits nous allons rouvrir 4000 pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps vous
avez un gouvernement qui dit par va
supprimer des postes à l'hôpital
on va embaucher 15000 soignant à
l'hôpital accompagné nous madame la
députée les choses vont dans le bon sens
et je suis sûr que vous les vôtres et la
semaine prochaine dans sept dans ce même
hémicycle
merci monsieur le ministre madame la
députée monsieur le ministre je vous
entends parfaitement et j'approuve
totalement tout ce qui a été fait lors
du premier ségur seulement la question
est là et vous le savez très bien les
passes les soignants sont tout
simplement épuisé et ne sont pas sûrs
d'être capable de refaire de faire face
à cette seconde vague du coc vide ce
qu'ils réclament tous et tous les
collectifs de soignants le réclament
c'est un deuxième secteur de la santé où
tous les soignants sont autour de la
table et puissent se parler des
possibilités et des propositions qu'ils
ont à faire c'est cela qu'il réclame et
rien d'autre et ce n'est en rien lié
l'action et les aime les mesures que
vous avez prises
merci d'un doublé monsieur le ministre
la députée aucune prime
aucune hausse de salaire n'enlèvera la
fatigue des soignants qui ont tout donné
pendant cette première vague nous devons
justement les soulager les épargner en
respectant les mesures barrières et en
faisant attention à ne pas faire
circuler le virus
par ailleurs nous avons développé la
formation des soignants pour qu'ils
puissent être opérationnels plus
nombreux en réanimation
rien qu'en ile de france sept étaient
750 infirmières ont été formés aux
pratiques de réanimation 300 de plus
seront avant le mois de décembre s'ils
accompagnent les joignant dans leur
lutte contre le virus
et soyons tous à la haute mer si
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
madame christine pires bonne
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre nos
collègues sénateurs viennent de rendre
un rapport suite à leur commission
denquête un rapport accablant sur les
concessions autoroutières un de plus me
direz vous tant il est vrai que ces
dernières années les rapports se
succèdent sans pour autant que les
différents gouvernements en tire des
conséquences les différentes mauvaise
opération de l'étang occasionné selon
vincent delahaye un manque à gagner
évalué entre 12 et 50 milliards selon le
périmètre retenu mais une lueur d'espoir
pointe son nez
les concessions arrivent à échéance
entre 2031 et 2036
au terme de celle ci les
concessionnaires devront restituer à
l'état propriétaire les infrastructures
gratuitement et en bon état d'entretien
monsieur le premier ministre on entend
dire que l'état aurait engagé des
discussions avec les majors du secteur
pouvez-vous nous rassurer et nous dire
aujourd'hui que ces discussions visent à
définir d'une part un bon état
d'entretien et d'autre part à définir
les modalités de retour à l'état mais en
aucun cas à étudier un possible
allongement de la durée des concessions
je vous remercie
merci vous avez vu que la parole à
monsieur olivier du soft ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
c'est sans doute
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée pires bonne vous avez rappelé
vous avez certainement raison
les modalités et les différentes étapes
successives et sur plusieurs
législatures qui ont concerné la
question des concessions autoroutières
vous avez aussi souligné le travail
réalisé par les sénateurs et la remise
du rapport dans le gouvernement s'est
saisi et que nous examinons puisque le
rapport porte à la fois des éléments de
constats des éléments de propositions
qui sont évidemment autant de
propositions et de constat intéressant
pour la suite et pour préparer une
échéance dont vous conviendrait qu elle
est encore assez lointaine nous n'avons
pas ouvert aujourd'hui de discussions
visant à prolonger par été renouvelés ou
apporter quelques modifications
substantielles que ce soit au contrat
évidemment l'état à un certain nombre de
contacts et échanges avec des
entreprises concessionnaires ce qui est
bien logique et nous avons d'une
certaine manière
l'obligation d'être dans ce type des
changes puisque à l'occasion des
dernières votre finance vous avez
certainement en tête le fait que nous
avons indexé un certain nombre de taxes
payées par les concessionnaires pour
garantir leur participation au
financement de certains ouvrages et je
pense notamment des ouvrages financés
par la fit comme le canal seine nord
nous continuerons à avoir ces relations
nous continuerons à le faire avec
vigilance et avec une ligne de mire un
objectif qui est de protéger l'intérêt
des français merci monsieur le ministre
madame la députée merci monsieur le
ministre j'ai donc entendu qu'il n'y
aurait pas de discussion mais vous mais
vous continuez quand même à discuter
avec les concessionnaires très bien de
se faire rappeler quand même quelques
chiffres de 2006 à 2010 9 ses 24 3
milliards de dividendes qui ont été
servis et les sénateurs ont évalué qu'à
terme des contrats des comptes rend à
iso distribution se seraient 70
milliards c'est-à-dire deux fois les
crédits 2021 du plan de relance
je vous dis ça parce que le rapport du
sénat indique aussi que s'il y avait une
seule mesure à retenir les sénateurs
nous dise ce serait de proscrire
l'allongement des durées de concession
donc j'insiste là dessus et je voudrais
que vous fassiez votre les propos de
madame bornes qui devant la commission
d' enquête du sénat de 10
et je pense qu'il faut arriver aux
termes de ces contrats les soldes et
passer à autre chose
originaire parole madame la députée un
mot pour vous remercier de la réponse à
la réponse vous avez raison de noter que
si des discussions formelles et des
négociations ne sont pas ouvertes comme
je l'aï indiqué il est bien évident que
l'état parce qu'il a cette
responsabilité doit continuer à mener
des discussions et je rappelais que nous
avons soumis les concessionnaires à une
indexation de taxes qui n'était pas
prévu initialement
la deuxième chose que vous avez évoquées
c'est la durée de ces opérations de 2006
à 2010 9 en rappelant des chiffres cités
par le rapport du sénat je pense que sur
ces deux aspects la préparation les
chances de 2030 devra réunir l'ensemble
des forces politiques pour que nous
puissions trouver un consensus et vos
propos me semble devoir nous y conduire
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
dans la sphère de l'opéra de veolia sur
suez c'est l'intérêt général qui est en
cause on parle de la gestion de l'eau et
des déchets en france d'un outil dont
nous aurons impérativement besoin pour
engager la bifurcation écologique
l'eau est un bien commun qui ne devrait
pas faire l'objet d'une guerre entre
actionnaires
si cette opé a été menée à son terme
nous pourrions craindre un scandale du
même type que celui des autoroutes des
prix à la hausse
un démantèlement de suez pour satisfaire
les exigences de la concurrence avec à
la clé plus de 4000 emplois menacés les
français n'ont aucun intérêt à la
constitution d'un monopole privé en la
matière mais mon sujet monsieur le
premier ministre
ce sont les mensonges du gouvernement et
votre duplicité dans cette affaire c'est
une trahison c'est un scandale détails
je vous le demande solennellement cessé
de nous prendre pour des imbéciles vous
le ferez croire à personne qu'en france
une entreprise peut lancer une opa
hostile contre suez où l'état est
totalement engagée sans qui les données
d'une manière ou d'une autre son feu
vert pour cette funeste opération bien
sûr pour sauver les apparences face au
français l'état a voté contre la cession
des actions suez détenu par angie à
veolia mais vous ne ferez croire à
personne non plus que l'état ait pu être
mis en minorité au sein de ce conseil
d'administration où est un des
principaux actionnaires sans que cette
mise en minorité et été organisée avec
sa propre complicité
c'est une farce il est temps de siffler
la fin de la récréation
pour messieurs macron et colère monsieur
frérot monsieur clamadieu
la france n'est pas un gibier dont on
s'offre les morceaux pour se faire des
cadeaux entre amis en récompense de bons
et loyaux services
nous demandons que l'assemblée nationale
se saisisse de cette affaire au travers
d'une commission denquête monsieur le
premier ministre votre réponse vous
engagera devant l'histoire
qu'avez vous à répondre aux révélations
du journal mediapart selon lesquelles
l'elysée serait intervenu directement
dans cette affaire contre l'intérêt
général à ton monsieur le ministre
comploté dans le dos des français dans
ce dossier et si oui qu avez-vous
l'intention de faire pour que les
comploteurs soit pour chasser et punis
merci monsieur débuté la parole à
monsieur olivier du choc du ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député quelle est la
position que l'état a tenu dans ce
dossier entre veolia et suez
nous avons défendu nous avons poursuivi
trois objectifs en permanence la
préservation de l'emploi et des
implantations le maintien d'une
concurrence saine entre les différents
opérateurs ce secteur sur le territoire
français et la volonté troisième
objectif que les choses se passent de la
manière la plus amicale s'ils ont pu
dire et en aucun cas dans le cadre d'une
opération
vous avez cité un article de presse en
demandant à monsieur le premier ministre
de se prononcer il suffisait d'écouter
les déclarations du gouvernement avec
son porte parole qui a démenti
l'intégralité de l'article et puis je
vais ajouter quelque chose qui peut vous
paraître étonnant mais lorsqu'on est
minoritaire dans un conseil
d'administration peut-être ou peut-être
mise en minorité
c'est la règle c'est la règle quand on
est minoritaire en pet mise en minorité
et l'état assume tout simplement
l'état assume tout simplement le fait de
des formes trois objectifs trois
objectifs sur lesquels nous restons
arquebouté et les actionnaires
ministre at her benji n'ont pas suivi la
position d'état ce qui est leur droit
même si nous le regrettons il ne s'agit
pas d'une prise de contrôle mais d'une
première étape
nous sommes convaincus qu'il y aura
encore des discussions
nous sommes convaincus qu'on peut
trouver qu'ils peuvent trouver entre la
possibilité de quelques un jeune d'un
scénario qui ne soit pas scénario
d'hostilité qui préserve le répète
l'emploi les implantations et la
concurrence merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à mme haddad d'alien
gazarian messieurs ministre des affaires
étrangères
dans quelques heures s'achèvera le 16e
jour de guerre on aura là bas ses jours
et ses nuits d'horreur de bombardement
délibéré des populations civiles
d'artsakh et d'arménie les journalistes
déployés sur place parlent d'un déluge
de missiles de ville devenue fantôme de
l'enfer de stepanakert la capitale
amnesty international a de son côté
dénoncé l' usage d'armes à sous
munitions ces armes qui n'ont pour objet
que la destruction aveugle des
populations civiles des crimes de guerre
ont lieu en ce moment même où on aura la
barre et c'est la mort qui attend les
arméniens depuis ses jours
les coprésidents du groupe de minsk au
premier rang desquels la france appelle
un cessez-le-feu et hausse le ton
je sais que vous la diplomatie française
ne ménageait pas vos efforts
mais la donne a changé l'azerbaïdjan est
désormais soutenu par la turquie qui lui
apporte un soutien diplomatique et
militaire l'a fourni en armes en drones
et en stratège de guerre notre président
de la république a clairement affirmé
que l'offensive azerbaïdjanaise était
injustifiée et que l'envoi de
mercenaires 10 à 10 par la turquie
constituait de franchissement d'une
ligne rouge keane et qu'il ne
l'accepterai pas il est temps de dire
stop au bellicisme d'ankara porteur d'un
risque majeur d'internationalisation du
conflit comme l'a souligné l'union
européenne monsieur finissent ministre
face à ces constats une position de
stricte neutralité n'est plus tenable on
aura la barre ce sont nos amis
combattent dans un rapport de force
inégal vous connaissez mon histoire mois
la petite fille de rescapés du génocide
arménien mais dans cet hémicycle et
surtout les bords de cette assemblée
dans un consensus inédit de la
représentation nationale
je veux le dire haut et fort nous sommes
tous des arméniens dans toute la france
nos collectivités s'investissent des
régions merci chers parents les chorus
yeux jean et le grillon ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
madame la députée danielle caserio vous
faites référence au conflit du haut
karabakh qui est un conflit des
affrontements les plus graves depuis
l'effondrement de l'urss
de nombreuses victimes au sein des
populations civiles sont à déplorer vous
avez rappelé que le président de la
république s'est exprimé publiquement
sur les conséquences graves surtout de
l'internationalisation de ce conflit
engagé internalisation engagé par la
turquie avec livraison d'armes et
mobilisation de mercenaires et je
souhaiterais souligner trois points
supplémentaires par rapport à votre
intervention d'abord je sais je
comprends l'émotion qu'ils suscitent en
france ce conflit avec toutes les
victimes qui s'en suivent avec le
ciblage inacceptable et populations
civiles cette émotion légitime exprime
cette émotion légitime exprime la
proximité des liens humains culturels
historiques qui nous lie à l'arménie je
connais votre histoire et je la respecte
et je comprends votre émotion
nous avons en effet une relations
bilatérales étroites avec ce pays et
vous le savez nous avons aussi une
longue relation avec eux l'azerbaïdjan
est donc nous devons nous coprésidents
du groupe de minsk utiliser des canots
bilatéraux pour faire pression sur les
deux parties pour consolider le
cessez-le-feu qui a été conclu dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche en g à moscou
en présence des deux autres coprésidents
ses dettes au monde mon représentant du
représentant américain pour que les
partis les deux parties respectent
strictement
le cessez le feu pour que les
affrontements cesse et je voudrais
rappeler un dernier point le mandat que
nous a confié löw et ce en 1994 avec la
russie les etats-unis posent une
exigence d'impartialité de la france
dans le contexte créé de crise du haut
karabakh ne serions plus légitime
si nous prenions parti pour l'un ou
l'autre des pays
je pense que nous ne rentrons pas
service à la qualité notre relation
bilatérale avec l'arménie si nous tenons
une posture déséquilibré qui remettrait
en cause le rôle que nous jouons dans le
cadre du groupe de minsk et qui
remettrait en cause une influence mais
nous pouvons avoir sur les parties en
crise merci monsieur le ministre la
parole devant la main véronique louwagie
si monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le plf 2021 est votre premier brute
budget et à ce stade sont jours après
votre installation à matignon les
associations restent les grandes
oubliées
laissez moi vous donner un exemple tout
simple celui des clubs sportifs
et je ne parle pas des clubs
professionnels qui eux aussi sont très
inquiet en ce moment je parle des petits
clubs comme ceux de chez moi
les clubs de charance et l'aigle
vimoutiers saint-ouen sur iton les âpres
pour ne parler que de quelques-uns
que nous dit le terrain il nous dit que
les associations sont aujourd'hui
grandement fragilisée il nous dit que la
crise a eu des impacts sur le
fonctionnement général des associations
qui n'ont plus d'activité génératrice de
ressources comme les lotos ou kermesse
il nous dit enfin que les impacts
financiers de la crise amène des
questions inquiétantes celle du dépôt de
bilan voire de la possibilité même de
maintenir des effectifs salariés quand
elles en ont et pourtant pourtant le
plan de relance ne fait qu'effleurer le
sujet et pourtant le monde associatif ne
voit rien venir
l'équation est simple pas d'argent pas
d'éducateurs et pas d'éducateurs ce sont
des jeunes sur le carreau
ma question est tout aussi simple que
compte faire le gouvernement pour que
ces associations et par ricochet la
dynamique des territoires ne s'éteigne
pas merci
la parole est à monsieur jean michel
blanc coeur ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée véronique louwagie
cette question est évidemment très
importante et vous avez bien raison de
souligner ce problème puisque le le
monde associatif est évidemment touché
comme d'autres secteurs de notre société
par ce qui s'est passé avec le
confinement et l'ensemble des
difficultés liées à la crise sanitaire
vous avez volontairement pris l'exemple
du domaine sportif et là aussi vous avez
bien raison parce que c'est
l'illustration très forte du sujet avec
à la fois des difficultés économiques
comme tous les acteurs de l'économie de
la société pendant le confinement et
puis des difficultés aujourd'hui pour
reprendre et ré attirer des personnes
bien sûr avec roxana maracineanu et
sarah et la grille nous sommes
extrêmement mobilisés sur cette question
d'abord il ya eu vous le savez plus de 3
milliards d'euros qui ont été consacrés
au monde sportif et donc notamment au
monde des associations sportives tant
dans le confinement dans le cadre des
mesures générales qui ont été prises
dans le cadre économique
il ya ensuite eu des mesures incitatives
au moment de la rentrée nous avons lancé
plusieurs campagnes notamment d'adhésion
aux associations sportives dont une qui
s'appelle envie de sport qui va au plus
près des territoires et qui s'accompagne
aussi de mesures très volontariste sur
le plan financier
c'est ainsi que l' agence nationale du
sport consacre 15 millions d'euros un
fonds de soutien pour les associations
et notamment les petits clubs au plus
près des territoires et que en plus de
cela car ce n'est pas là la seule mesure
prise
nous avons prévu dans le cadre du plan
de relance
et c'est notamment sur ce point que vous
nous interrogé 122 millions d'euros
destinés justement au volet sport
bien sûr ceci ne résume pas tout ce qui
est fait car c'est au travers de
l'ensemble de l'action gouvernementale
que la vie associative est encouragé sa
excède le temps de ma réponse est
évidemment mais il est évident que nous
allons totalement mobilisée au service
des associations et au service du monde
du sport merci monsieur ministre madame
la députée oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur monsieur le ministre
votre réponse nous fait un petit état de
ce qui a été fait mais il n'y a pas de
piste concrètement je vous propose deux
pistes que vous pourriez retenir la
première c'est vrai établir les contrats
aidés pour ces associations c'est une
et demande et la deuxième c'est de
mettre en place un fonds de solidarité
en faveur du monde associatif
alors comme les sportifs le dise la
balle est dans votre camp saisissez là
n'oublions pas que les conséquences de
la crise continuent à apparaître alors
sauver nos associations
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur christian hutin
[Applaudissements]
mais merci monsieur le président tous
les professionnels soignants malades du
que vides seront reconnus au titre des
maladies professionnelles sans exception
déclaration du 21 avril 2021
conditionnelle de monsieur le ministre
de la santé des sociétés
olivier ferrand il ya trois semaines
mardi a été signé un arrêté un arrêté
alors si je suis très poli il est
extrêmement restrictif
il est tout petit et des minables si
j'entends le lendemain ce que disent les
présidents des grands syndicats français
ils disent qu'il aimait prix 100 je
demande à monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui de revenir sur cet arrêté
qui est absolument terrible j'ai un
exemple tout simple tout simple l'or
mais très simple alors le prenons
d'abord la politique
politiquement c'est arrêté ne peut pas
continuer à être comme il est c'est
impossible de continuer à dire que ces
gens qui ont servi la france ne seront
pas servis comme la france de les servir
la deuxième chose il ya un député qui
s'appelle révèle gérard je ne connais
pas qui doit être un type extraordinaire
mais qui en a bavé quand un malade comme
beaucoup de types ici parce que des gens
qui sont morts ici dans cet hémicycle
dans cet hémicycle
eh bien je dis que si on peut s'inspirer
un peu des conséquences et des séquelles
que peut donner le codi d'aujourd'hui il
faut obligatoirement revoir votre copie
monsieur le ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député christian hutin vous confondez
tout et c'est bien dommage mais je vous
le dis votre question il cache ma
réponse est cash monsieur monsieur le
député je vous prie de se tutoyer député
faucon
c'est un décret qui a été pris sur la
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle et qui reconnaît
obligatoirement est automatiquement
comme une maladie professionnelle toutes
maladies causées par le cos beach et un
soignant ou chez un professionnel des
aides ou des services aux domiciles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire monsieur
débuté ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'ils
aient une maladie professionnelle
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
maladie évolutive du coc vide il
maladies professionnelles que ce soit
dans le cadre d'une intoxication à
l'amiante dans le cas d'accident lorsque
vous avez une invalidité et là nous
avons retenu le seuil de 10% qui est
extrêmement faible
ça veut dire si vous gardez la moindre
séquelles respiratoires et que vous êtes
soignants ou que vous aide à domicile on
ne vous demande pas de démontrer qu'il
avait été contaminée dans le cadre de
votre activité professionnelle
on considère que deux fêtes c'est une
maladie professionnelle avec une
reconnaissance c'est ça que gilles
décret et c'est ça qui est totalement
nouveau donc oui je le dis un soignant
qui a été contaminée par le cos vide
mais qui ne garde pas de séquelles n'est
donc pas en maladie professionnelle
c'est la définition même monsieur le
député la maladie procès elle que
d'avoir des séquelles au long cours et
si il y as et kelly la reconnaissance
automatique
pour celles et ceux qui ne sont pas des
soignants ou des acteurs du domicile
eh bien nous avons une reconnaissance
qui est possible via une expertise de la
même manière que cette expertise existe
pour tous les cas d'intoxication
professionnels et de maladie
professionnelle c'est le travail que
nous avons fourni et c'est l'objet de ce
décret merci monsieur le député monsieur
le ministre nous avons clairement il ne
voit possible une voie législative qui
sait que avec régis juanico moi même
votre serviteur des rabots et l'ensemble
des députés du groupe socialiste
nous avons tout ce qu'il faut pour
défendre l'ensemble de la création d'un
fonds d'indemnisation des victimes
pas seulement
ce qui est au premier rang les autres
aussi la caissière de calais merci
monsieur le député ministre
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois c'est la première fois
qu'une reconnaissance automatique de
l'origine d'une maladie professionnelle
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du droit vous connaissez la branche at
mp dans le plfss c'est la première fois
et pour toutes les autres première ligne
la reconnaissance est tout à fait
possible par une expertise et ça existe
dans le droit commun depuis des années
et des années et par ailleurs s'il y a
des indemnisations pour des aléas ou
pour des coûts des questions
d'indemnisation spécifique
l'awb a abordé la question d'un fonds
d'indemnisation ne pose pas de
difficulté de fait partie du débat
parlementaire la porte est ouverte
donc monsieur le député reconnaissant
que les choses ont été bien amenée
jusqu'à présent continu ont l'air ce
sujet le ministre la parole est à
monsieur hubert wulfranc alors monsieur
le ministre de la santé voyons la parole
du président le 6 octobre à l'hôpital
rothschild qui répondant à une
interpellation donc des soignants sur la
situation sanitaire disait je cite ce
n'est pas une question moyens mais
d'organisation
il a ajouté on ne va pas créer des
postes et délits parce que le coc vide
arrive là c'est impossible
ces propos nous la prenons comme une
véritable gifle aux français au regard
de ce que vit notre pays les hôpitaux et
les soignants chacun ont fait le constat
souffre d'un manque de lits d'un manque
de personnel
certes nous payons le désengagement des
gouvernements qui ont précédé et que
vous avez accentué 2002 puis 2017 en
supprimant 7600 lit et en prélevant 4
milliards près de 4 milliards sur le
budget des hôpitaux mais vous êtes
aujourd'hui en situation d'affirmer
pouvoir atteindre les 12 mille lits de
réanimation
ceci étant il était verrez que le
personnel fait des fonds pour faire
fonctionner les 5000
existants dix pour cent d'entre eux sont
fermés en permanence et il est désormais
demandé aux soignants de renoncer à
leurs congés alors ma question
si vous n'êtes en mesure d'embaucher et
de fermer du jour au lendemain depuis
six mois comme l'indiqué monsieur le
premier ministre
ce que vous avez largement nuancé tout à
l'heure en disant oui embauchions forme
si nos personnels ne peuvent être
conduits jusque l'éreintement totale
face à cette deuxième vague
comment allez-vous ouvrière si
nécessaire ses douze mille mercis la
parole est à monsieur olivier vers
enregistre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député villefranche je
confirme il faut toujours 10 à 12 ans
pour former un anesthésiste réanimateur
et nous avons supprimé cette majorité a
supprimé le numerus clausus il ya deux
ans donc de fait
de fait est hélas hélas le numerus
clausus a été supprimée trop tard il a
fallu que nous arrivions pour le
supprimer monsieur le député c'est un
fait ça fait 40 ans qu'il existe
l'année où j'ai passé le concours de
médecine monsieur le député nous étions
trois mille sept cents médecins formés
par an en france
nous sommes désormais plus de 9000
médecins formés par an france et demain
je souhaite qu'il y en ait encore
davantage pour combler les trous à vide
dans la ville comme à l'hôpital mais ça
prend du temps
effectivement comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure de la même manière pour former
un infirmier en service de réanimation
il faut beaucoup de temps et ça ne se
fait pas évidemment six mois mais
néanmoins les hôpitaux par le
gouvernement les hôpitaux ne sont pas
tourné les pouces et ont engagé des
programmes de formation express
notamment sur simulateur je les ai vus
dans les territoire de belfort et à
grenoble la semaine dernière 750
infirmières ont été formés pour pouvoir
prêter main forte
rien qu'en d'île de france et ça compte
et c'est important vous avez raison
monsieur le député lorsque vous dites
qu'on a un enjeu de ressources humaines
avec des soignants qui sont fatigués des
soignants qui sont mobilisés et notre
volonté de ne pas annuler ou retarder
des soins qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
co vide mais qui sont essentiels pour la
santé des français
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi nous luttons le plus
farouchement possible avec le plus de
vigueur possible contre la circulation
de ce virus
pour ne pas arriver dans une situation
de catastrophe qui nous obligerait à
nouveau des programmes et tous les soins
dans les hôpitaux pour mettre toutes les
ressources vers des lignes réanimation
monsieur le député nous sommes montés le
15 avril dernier au coeur de la tempête
à 10700 lee armée de réanimation nous
avons désormais douze mille respirateur
des médicaments de réanimation pour
soigner jusqu'à 29 mille malades en même
temps vous l'imaginez bien parce que
nous n'aurions pas les lits pour ça nous
appelons toutes les bonnes volontés des
soignants pour venir renforcer les
effectifs et se préparer dans
l'hypothèse de cette deuxième vague
encore une fois cet homme doit être
l'objet d'un consensus national
extrêmement fort nous sommes tous dans
le même bateau face à cette vague merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur wulfranc
quelques secondes
non il faut le sang neuf balesi pour
neuf mais il y en avait cinq c'est pas
grave
allez-y monsieur le ministre il ya quand
même malveillance délibéré parce que moi
si je si j'écoute les annonces qui
viennent de tomber
au niveau du chu d'horreur ou vrai il ya
80 suppressions de lits en psychiatrie
et 20 les buts et 9 c pas 10 la parole
est à monsieur philippe berta merci
monsieur le président cette question
s'adresse à nous celui sur les
solidarités de la santé et je souhaite y
associer notre collègue michel fanget 20
ans 20 ans élégante le gars d'espérance
de vie obtenue par l'espèce humaine de
nos sociétés occidentales et ceci en
quelques décennies
si l'offre thérapeutique a explosé
explose dans bien des domaines
il ne reste pas mois que ce sont bien
vaccination et antibiotiques qui reste
la base de cette progression
si l'antibiothérapie antibiothérapie
pardon fait l'objet d'abus en santé
humaine comme animal
la vaccination a été et reste la cible
de régulières de fausses nouvelles
amplifiée par les réseaux sociaux et
quelques mauvais esprit l'éradication de
la poliomyélite par la voix vaccinale en
afrique et pour toi nouveau succès tout
juste annoncée par le ms certains
feignent de ne pas savoir que l'accès à
une thérapie il repose sur un rapport
bénéfice risque
favorables ce qui n'exclut en aucun cas
la possibilité d'effets secondaires
rencontrer dans quelques cas la
recherche de thérapeutique pour contrer
la pandémie comme vidic
ceci à travers de multiples essais
cliniques réalisés dans le monde entier
basé sur le repositionnement
d'antiviraux préexistants n'a pas à ce
jour abouti aux résultats escomptés
notre espoir réside essentiellement dans
l'obtention d'un ou de plusieurs vaccins
dans les mois et les moyens et les
pouvoirs peut-être les années à venir
tout en mesurant la difficulté de sa bio
production à destination des 7 milliards
d'êtres humains
mais voilà les sondages se suivent et se
ressemblent il atteste de la méfiance
voire du rejet d'une bonne frange de la
population française vis-à-vis de l'acte
vaccinal et ceci indépendamment de la
cible et de l'urgence sanitaire
n'est-il pas temps monsieur le ministre
de développer une communication massive
empreinte de culture scientifique un
adresse du plus grand nombre
sans oublier le monde de l'éducation
l'enseignement supérieur nombreux
l'infectiologue immunologiste alerte
depuis quelques semaines sur le risque
d'une épidémie de grippe se rajouter
dans les jours à venir
cette double circulation virale
préférant courir un risque risque que
vital majeurs en particulier pour les
plus âgés d'entre nous ne serait-il pas
indispensable d'envisager la vaccination
obligatoire des personnels de santé et
des personnels accompagnants aurons-nous
des doses de vaccin antigrippal
nécessaire devant ce qui reste d'être
une demande sans égal je vous remercie
merci avec la parole à monsieur olivier
véran ministre des solidarités et de la
santé merci monsieur le député bertha
pour votre question sur la vaccination
dans le pays de pasteur
force est de reconnaître que le recul de
la confiance dans la vaccination par les
français ce recul est de plus en plus
important il est de plus en plus graves
il est parfois alimentés par une partie
des élites mais je pense notamment même
à certains élus sur certains bancs et
également certains élus maires de
grandes communes de france qui peuvent
avoir un discours à minima plutôt
sceptique sur les vaccins et qui
participe de la perte de confiance dans
la population c'est un débâcle devrions
avoir même en dehors d'une crise
épidémique dit comment restaurer la
confiance dans la parole scientifique
dans ce cas-là de réseau n'est pas dans
ce cas-là de disparates ou dans ce
cas-là d'éclater ou dans ce cas-là 2
de prophétique ça chantait prophétie
jusqu'à présent depuis le début de la
crise monsieur le député vous
remarquerez avec moi ce sont toutes
percuté sur le mur de la réalité
nous devons donc encourager les français
à se faire vacciner je les dis un vaccin
doit être sûrs et efficaces s'agissant
du coc vide et s'agissant de la
vaccination antigrippale la campagne
commence le 13 octobre ce 13 octobre et
elle vise en priorité les populations
vulnérables ainsi que les soignants et
les acteurs du domicile qui peuvent être
en contact avec des publics fragiles et
vulnérables notre objectif c'est de
hausser le niveau de couverture de ces
populations fragiles spécifiques
sachant que nous sommes très en retard
en france leurs maîtres commande qu'on
atteigne au moins 75% de la cible nous
dépassons plus et 50% depuis des années
y compris d'ailleurs chez les soignants
monsieur députés nous nous sommes posé
la question de rendre le vaccin
antigrippal obligatoire chez les
soignants
nous ne faisons pas pour une raison
assez simple c'est que nous avons besoin
de la mobilisation de tous les soignants
je répondais tout à l'heure aux députés
ville francs là dessus et que nous
allons peur que rendre obligatoire la
vaccination entraîne un certain nombre
de retraits et nous avons besoin de ces
soignants par contre nous encourageons
et nous comptons sur toutes les bonnes
volontés dans ce pays parlementaires
élus scientifiques citoyens pour faire
en sorte que les soignants se vaccine et
pour faire en sorte que les potes les
populations vulnérables regard de la
grippe puissent être vaccinés et
protégez nous n'ajoutons pas le fléau
d'une épidémie sur le fluo déjà
existants si monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame sabine rubin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale ii
plateaux télé en plateau télé vous
n'avez cessé de répéter tout est prêt
pour la rentrée
or rien n'était prêt en septembre sauf
un protocole est inapplicable écrit à la
va-vite quatre jours avant cette rentrée
est laissée à la libre interprétation de
chaque collectivité ainsi la
distanciation social n'est ni respectés
ni respectable locaux exigus nombre
d'agents d'entretien insuffisant masques
et produits en sous-nombre entre autres
mais alors que le virus progresse
partout notamment chez les jeunes et que
les contraintes sanitaires drastiques se
multiplient vous monsieur le ministre
paradoxalement vous ne cessez de
relâcher votre surveillance cas contacts
non tracés si l'élève est assez
symptomatique
classe non fermées en deçà de trois cas
positifs pourtant santé publique france
nous alertent 36 pour cent des 1000 et 1
kloster en cours d'investigation se
trouve en milieu scolaire ou
universitaire alors que l'on note comme
le premier ministre l'a rappelé un
rajeunissement des hospitalisations
par ailleurs un article de reporter nous
apprend aujourd'hui que les masques dim
que vous avez distribués au personnel
représentent un risque tant pour leur
santé que pour l'environnement car
traiter à l'aser à la zéolithe d'argent
monsieur le ministre nous avons tous un
coeur de protéger la santé des 12
millions d'élèves ainsi que des
personnels qu'il est formé en cas d' or
salutaire rappel le 31 mai dernier
vous pouviez dire si le virus est
toujours là à la rentrée il y aura
toujours la règle de groupes restreints
un mois après la rentrée la deuxième
vague submerge nos écoles comment pensez
vous donc vous mettre en conformité avec
vos propres déclarations
merci la parole et à monsieur jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
savine rubin l'école est l'épiné dorsale
de notre pays elle est aussi l'épiné
dorsale de notre république
à chaque fois qu'elle a des réussites on
devrait se réjouir en commun de ces
réussites
plutôt que de chercher de vaines
polémiques je sais que vous êtes plutôt
dans ce registre les vaines polémiques
et donc je vais répondre à ce que vous
venez de tient d'abord je vous ai déjà
plusieurs fois répondu la france est le
pays qui a le mieux réussi ou qui fait
partie des pays qui ont le mieux réussi
leur rentrée scolaire
vous devriez en être heureuse grâce à
cela nous avons douze millions d'élèves
qui sont rentrés en france
bien des pays serait heureux de pouvoir
en dire autant réjouissez vous si vous
aimez l'école tout simplement
deuxièmement vous vous demandez si les
conditions sanitaires ont été remplies
vous dites que le protocole sanitaire a
été préparé quatre jours avant je me
souviens de vous nous reprochant de
l'avoir élaboré au mois de juillet et
disons que fin août c'était ça posait un
problème d'adaptation
en réalité nous l'avons adopté en
juillet
en effet et nous l'avons adopté adapté
fin août
parce que c'est la bonne méthode d'avoir
un cadre qui a été fixé bien en avance
et ensuite des mesures d'adaptation en
fonction des situations que nous
rencontrons les chiffres que nous avons
ne sont pas des mauvais chiffres
aujourd'hui ce sont des chiffres qui
sont très comparables aux autres
secteurs de la société
lorsque santé publique france agrège
écoles collèges lycées et universités
cela ne permet pas d'avoir la bonne
focale tout simplement ce que la réalité
des universités n'a rien à voir avec
celle des écoles des collèges et des
lycées et que lorsque l'on parle de cela
on parle d'une population de plus de 15
millions de personnes est donc normal
que ça fasse du monde
ensuite ce qu'on appelle les clusters
qu'on devrait d'ailleurs appelé des
foyers en bon français eh bien ces
foyers ne représente que 20% des
contaminations
donc ce que vous avez dit effet pour
effrayer et ne correspond pas à une
réalité de contamination particulière
dans nos écoles depuis ses jours il ya
5000 279 élèves soit 0 04 % des élèves
qui sont atteints par le virus
et comme vous le savez chez les enfants
cela ne se traduit pas par des symptômes
particulièrement grave
nous avons 24 structures scolaires
fermés sur 60 milles donc voyez madame
la députée marie-line suis inquiète et
je vous remercie madame le député
monsieur le ministre vous savez que les
enfants fréquentent des adultes et par
ailleurs vous qui aimez les comparaisons
avec nos pays voisins
regardez du côté de l'italie qui a
ouvert cinq mille classes
supplémentaires et a agrandi sa me
classent également merci madame le
député la parole commission taux dits
scellier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur le
ministre depuis bientôt deux ans avec
mes collègues parlementaires de la
majorité et le gouvernement
nous travaillons pour mettre fin aux
garanties publiques à l'export pour des
projets d'énergies fossiles
ces garanties de l'état sont un levier
puissant à notre disposition pour ne
plus financer à l'étranger des projets
que nous nous interdisons nous
interdisons pardon sur notre propre sol
c'est également un levier important pour
préparer les entreprises françaises aux
enjeux majeurs de décarbonation qui
seront demain j'en suis convaincu les
critères de performance et de
compétitivité sur les marchés
internationaux
je salue donc les avancées que nous
avons apportées en moins de deux ans sur
la fin du soutien au charbon aux
hydrocarbures non conventionnels ou
encore auto recherche de routine et la
mise en place d'outils de mesure de
l'empreinte carbone du portefeuille de
bpi france
hier nous avons annoncé de nouvelles
dispositions dans le cadre du plan
climat pour les finances export la mise
en place d'un mécanisme de bonus dédié
aux entreprises qui portent des projets
durables est en pointe sur la transition
énergétique la fin dès 2021 du soutien
au pétrole extra-lourd et aux sables
bitumineux la fin pour 2025 c'est à dire
dans cinq ans du soutien aux nouveaux
gisements pétroliers et la fin du
soutien aux nouveaux gisements de gaz je
le souhaite bien avant 2035 si nous
voulons être en phase avec l'accord de
paris monsieur le ministre
l'enjeu climatique et mondial une partie
de la solution est européenne
l'exemplarité elle doit être nationale
si la france ambitionne de devenir la
plus grande économie décarbonée
européenne pouvez vous nous dire comment
elle fédère et entraîne les autres états
vers la fin du soutien à l'export des
énergies fossiles
tant au niveau européen qu'au niveau
mondial je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur olivier dussopt ministre
délégué chargé des comptes publics je
tiens à préciser que l'absence d'un
certain nombre de membres du
gouvernement est lié aux distanciation
refuge et non pas des activités ludiques
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
scellier vous avez dit l'essentiel pour
votre question vous travaillez avec de
nombreux parlementaires je pense aux
députés holroyd de députés au député
colas au député st martin comme à portée
générale ou encore à bénédicte pérol
tous ceux qui vous accompagne pour
construire cette stratégie de
décarbonation et compris pour eux les
financements export de manière à ce que
l'état dans son comportement et dans ce
financement
cet exemplaire à l'export comme il l'est
et comme nous voulons lettre pour
l'économie nationale
ce rapport et ce travail que vous avez
fourni à a nourri la stratégie du
gouvernement en la matière et hier vous
avez l'occasion aux côtés de bruno le
maire mise de l'économie et des finance
de participer à la présentation de cette
stratégie export en tout cas de
financement export
vous l'avez dit à compter du 1er janvier
2021 c'est demain ne financerons plus
ils n'accorderont pas de financement
export et de garanties pour les
exploitations qui exploite du pétrole
extra-lourd ou encore les hydrocarbures
les hydrocarbures non conventionnels
de la même manière nous cesserons de
garantir les opérations qui visent à
permettre l'exploitation de nouveaux
gisements de pétrole à partir du 1er
janvier 2000 25
et pour ce qui concerne le gaz vous
l'avez dit la date est fixée à 2035 avec
une actualisation permanente de cette
date la volonté aussi de s'inscrire dans
le long terme
mais s'il est possible de le faire plus
tôt ne le feront plus tôt conformément
aux attentes que vous et des
parlementaires que j'ai évoqué avait
exprimé il faut pouvoir avancer en la
matière et nous avancerons aussi en
faisant en sorte d'accompagner la
production d'électricité à l'étranger
uniquement lorsque ces nouvelles ces
nouvelles unités de production
permettront de renouveler d'améliorer le
mix énergétique des pays d'accueil
il faut aller plus loin ne pas être que
dans une attitude qui ne l'ont défensive
au d'interdiction c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous envisageons et vous l'avez
noté des bonus pour les garanties qui
s'appuieront et qui elles permettront
d'appuyer pardon des projets qui
s'inscrivent en cohérence et en
application de l'accord de paris c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
voulons faire preuve d'exemplarité par
une cotation
il nous faut entraîner nos partenaires
il faut entraîner les signataires
l'écran de paris c'est soit que nous
travaillons avec vous dans les
prochaines semaines merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à madame nathalie soeur
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
savez vous qui a dit récemment on n'y
comprend plus rien ce n'est pas bien
gérée et ce n'est pas bien expliqué et
bien c'est le président de la république
lui-même la presse nous présente
d'ailleurs son intervention télévisée de
demain soir comme un recadrage du
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre la réalité de vos 100 premiers
jours c'est que votre gestion
d'aujourd'hui est pire que celle d'hier
comme si vous n'avez rien appris de vos
erreurs confinement déconfinement
confinement effectivement les français
ont bien du mal à vous suivre
quand vous naviguez à vue
sans ligne directrice et sans méthode
pire encore votre communication et votre
gestion ont tendance à opposer les
français les jeunes et les aînés
les cafetiers et les restaurateurs les
rassemblements privé et les soirées
organisées les urbains et les ruraux
monsieur le premier ministre nous
l'avons vu nos compatriotes sont prêts à
beaucoup de sacrifices pour enrayer
cette pandémie mais ils ont besoin de
clarté et de cohérence pour adhérer à
vos mesures on nous annonce de nouvelles
décisions dans les prochaines heures et
on nous dit que le gouvernement pourrait
prendre des mesures de restriction des
libertés jusqu'à la fin mars 2021
le climat est anxiogène au sein de la
population française
les élus locaux et les acteurs de
terrain se sentent abandonnés par l'état
qui leur imposent des décisions d'en
haut
les secteurs économiques touchés veulent
se rebeller monsieur le premier ministre
entendez-vous l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens alors que la crise sanitaire
est appelée à durer
quand allez-vous proposer une politique
claire et cohérente qui permettra à tous
les français de continuer à vivre le
temps de ce virus
faudra-t-il pour cela attendre la
déclaration du président de la
république de demain soir qui ne ferait
donc plus confiance à votre gouvernement
je vous remercie vous même le député la
parole de monsieur olivier ferrand mehdi
sur des solidarités et de la santé
madame la députée comme on dit tout
augmente
avant vous attendiez qu'on ait fait des
annonces pour dire que ça ne marcherait
pas et qu'elles sont nuls
maintenant vous anticipez on n'a pas
encore ouvrir la bouche vous êtes déjà
en train de dire qu'elles sont nuls
c'est quand même formidable j'aimerais
vous remercier j'aurais vous remercier
pour toute l'énergie que vous mettez
comme parlementaire a aidé le
gouvernement aider les français à lutter
avec efficacité contre une épidémie qui
tue contre une épidémie qui fait des
malades qui remplit deux hôpitaux
je crois que franchement c'est être
parfaitement la hauteur de vos fonctions
que de vous donnez nous la donnait une
politique une polémique comme celle ci
madame la députée personne n'a dit que
l'épidémie à coronavirus détestable né
en france ni à l'étranger
personne n'a considéré qu'il y avait à
ce jour toutes les connaissances sur le
virus permettant de prendre
pile poil au bon moment et les bonnes
mesures ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que nous faisons le maximum avec les
scientifiques avec les médecins avec les
élus dans les territoires qu'ils ont je
crois à madame
la députée manifestement ça ne semble
pas être votre cas la nécessité absolue
de faire preuve de cohésion et de
courage ensemble pour nous battre aux
côtés des français contre cette épidémie
et finir par vaincre ce virus par
vaincre ce virus les mesures et notre
stratégie madame la députée ont été
présentées elles le seront à chaque fois
que ce sera nécessaire adaptées à chaque
territoire adaptée à l'état de
circulation du virus dans chaque
métropole dans chaque métropole dans
chaque département elles sont ajustés
pour ne pas inutilement réduire les
libertés publiques mais adapter le
niveau de contraintes au niveau de
circulation du virus pour protéger les
hôpitaux sauver des vies et en finir
avec le virus madame la députée encore
une fois au printemps dernier il avait
dans ce parlement sur l'ensemble des
bancs des députés qui concerne la
gravité du moment et des prêts étaient
capables de faire preuve d'union
nationale et d'unité je crois dans la
période cette unité
elle est indispensable merci monsieur le
ministre avant de lui donner la parole
je suis heureux de souhaiter la
bienvenue à notre collègue monsieur
grégory labille devenu député de la 5e
circonscription de la somme le 8 octobre
dernier en remplacement de monsieur
stéphane demi
chers collègues vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre
samedi 21 septembre 2019 christine
renaud ma collègue directrice de
maternelle à pantin se donner la mort à
58 ans dans son école en laissant une
lettre dénonçant la dégradation de ses
conditions de travail
trois pages détaillant la solitude le
stress et l'accumulation des tâches
administratives chronophage samedi 23
mai 2020 bruno delbecque mon collègue
directeur d'école à saint laurent du var
à 64 ans et alors qu'il allait prendre
sa retraite à la fin de l'année scolaire
se suicide
enseignant depuis près de 30 ans dont
5,1 dont cinq années de direction
d'école j'aurais tendance à dire que
rien n'a changé depuis ces deux drames
pire les directeurs que j'ai pu
rencontrer souligne une dégradation au
fil des années on leur demande de faire
toujours plus toujours mieux avec des
moyens humains et matériels limités une
reconnaissance financière insuffisante
si l'enseigné est le plus beau métier du
monde
il ne doit pas devenir un objet de
souffrance pour les enseignants les
directeurs d'école sont des
professionnels animés d'une passion
réelle avec des missions variées depuis
des années leur métier a beaucoup changé
vous en avez l'occasion au travers de la
proposition de loi créant la fonction de
directeur d'école voter dans cet
hémicycle au mois de juin dernier et
notre groupe avait formulé un certain
nombre de propositions par la voix de
notre collègue béatrice descamps
mais ce texte monsieur le ministre n'est
plus qu'une coquille vide
abandon de la décharge totale
d'enseignement au delà de huit classes
rien pour les territoires ruraux une
aide administrative qui dépendra des
communes sans leur octroyer de moyens
supplémentaires
ce texte a suscité beaucoup d'espoir ne
les laissez pas se transformer en
frustration monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous vous saisir de ce vecteur
législatives pour améliorer le quotidien
de nos directeurs d'école merci monsieur
débuté la parole est à monsieur jean
michel blanquer venise de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
grégory labille votre question porte sur
un des sujets les plus importants qui
soit celui des directeurs et directrices
d'école il ya plus de directrice que
directeur il faut quand même toujours le
souligner et vous avez raison de
rappeler le drame qui nous a tous émus
l'année dernière et aussi d'autres
drames qui peuvent exister comme ceux
que vous avez mentionné
il y à vous le savez des progrès très
importants qui ont été faits vous avez
eu raison aussi de mentionner la
proposition de loi de la députée cécile
rida qui justement montre que nous
sommes sur un chemin de d'avancé et puis
il ya aussi toutes les mesures que j'ai
pu prendre pour la rentrée que je vais
vous rappeler puisque vous ne les avez
pas mentionné mais s'agissant la
proposition de loi de mme adam reed ac
dont je rappelle qu'elle a fait l'objet
de très nombreuses concertations vous
considérer qu'elle a été vidé de sa
substance
mais d'autres que vous qui eux aussi
considère qu'il faut améliorer le sort
des directeurs d'école ne sont pas du
tout d'accord avec la solution que vous
proposez donc nous savons très bien que
n'y a pas de consensus sur ce sujet et
avec la députée nous cherchons à créer
ce consensus parce qu'en effet il y a
des progrès à faire mais tout le monde
pas le sujet de la même façon donc ce
n'est pas que le gouvernement ne veuille
pas telle ou telle avancée c'est que
nous avons à créer les conditions de ce
consensus
ensuite nous avons fait des efforts très
importants en cette rentrée de façon
générale tous les efforts que nous
faisons pour l'école primaire
évidemment je l'espère rejaillissent
quand même sur le quotidien des
directeurs d'école je pense au
dédoublement des classes
je pense tout simplement au taux
d'encadrement à l'école primaire qui
s'est améliorée pour cette rentrée c'est
unique dans nos annales dans chaque
commune de france je prends l'exemple de
paris il ya deux élèves par classe en
moins depuis trois ans
si on fait le bilan sur trois ans donc
ces améliorations elles font partie
aussi du quotidien de l'école primaire
nous avons aussi créé des nouveau
service civique pour cette rentrée une
prime de 450 euros pour les directeurs
d'école des décharges administratifs qui
seront votés pour l'an prochain dans une
proportion qui reste encore à définir
et puis nous avons tout un travail qui
continue c'est vrai avec la députée
cécile relax et aussi dans le cadre du
grenelle de l'éducation qui s'ouvre dans
en cours de ce mois d'octobre
et donc oui il ya des progrès à faire
j'en suis d'accord avec vous mais nous
pouvons être sur un chemin d'optimisme
et je vous remercie de faire partie de
ce chemin d'optimisme merci merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur benoit fuyant
merci monsieur le président même la
ministre de la transition écologique ou
devrais-je dire de l'urgence écologique
mes chers collègues en 2018 à l'occasion
de l'examen budgétaire
nous avions voté un amendement
magnifique concernant la presqu'île du
médoc
en effet notre assemblée avait décidé
d'indemniser par un déblocage de 7
millions d'euros les habitants du signal
un immeuble situé sur la côte de
soulac-sur-mer duquel il avait été
duquel avaient été expropriés sans
ménagement et surtout sans un sou les
habitants pour replacer un peu la
situation dans son contexte il faut
rappeler que suite aux tempêtes de
l'hiver 2013 2014 et de la forte érosion
observé à cette occasion l'immeuble
désormais situé à quelques mètres de
l'océan avait fait l'objet le 24 janvier
2014 d'un arrêté municipal pris par le
maire de soulac sur mer xavier pintât
d'évacuation et d'interdictions
d'occupation face au risque
d'effondrement ses 75 copropriétaires
avaient été contraints d'évacuer les
lieux sans qu'une procédure
d'expropriation été déclenchée l'érosion
dunaire ne faisant pas partie
contrairement
celle de la côte rocheuse comme chez
vous monsieur le président en bretagne
des conditions justifiant le recours au
fond dit barnier
les copropriétaires n'ont pu être
indemnisés
le conseil d'état dans sa décision du 16
août 2010 8 avait malheureusement
confirmé cette injustice cette injustice
a conduit du fait des copropriétaires à
payer de leur poche les charges de la
copropriété vouera contracter de
nouveaux crédits pour financer un bien
dont il était dépossédé
depuis des années cette injustice
sociale mes chers collègues nous l'avons
ont réparé lorsque de façon collective
et trans partisane
nous avons réorienté les crédits
budgétaires à 2 heures du matin à la
faveur de ses habitants les et lorsque
avec les équipes de nicolas hulot et de
brune poirson
nous avons débloqué un million d'euros
pour le désamiantage du bâtiment
nous savons que ce dossier a subi des
lourdeurs administratives du fait d'un
vide juridique français à savoir que
notre droit ne reconnaît pas l'érosion
comme relevant d'une catastrophe même si
monsieur le député malgré un ministre
j'aimerais de la transition écologique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et député monsieur le député
signant vous l'avez dit l'immeuble du
signal a été évacué en 2014 et depuis
nous avons travaillé avec votre aide et
avec l'aide de nombreux collègues à
adopter un régime d'indemnisation pour
les propriétaires de cet immeuble menacé
par le recul du trait de côte et
effectivement parce que dans l'état
actuel du droit il n'y a pas de
dispositif permettant d'indemniser les
propriétaires de biens atteint par
l'érosion
tout d'abord en 2010 9,1 l'état a
procédé à ses frais au désamiantage de
l'immeuble un million d'euros vous
l'avez rappelé puis des amendements
successifs d'abord celui que vous avez
porté en loi de finances 2010 9 a adopté
une enveloppe de 7 millions pour
indemniser les propriétaires des biens
atteint par l'érosion et enfin un
amendement adopté en loi de finances
rectificative pour 2020 présentée par le
gouvernement précise les modalités
d'indemnisation des propriétaires de
l'immeuble signal il est prévu une
indemnité de prise en charge par l'état
à hauteur de 70% de la valeur vénale
déterminer
traction fait du risque d'effondrement
du bien concerné les services de l'état
en lien avec la collectivité travaille à
la mise en oeuvre de ces dispositions
il y a deux protocoles transactionnels
qui sont en voie de finalisation un
protocole cadre entre états commune et
opci et un protocole filles entre étape
pci est propriétaire le protocole 4 va
pouvoir et signer très rapidement
normalement dans le courant du mois
d'octobre et les protocoles fille avec
chaque propriétaire seront signés plus
tard car ça nécessite vous en doutez de
les réunir et de faire signer chacun les
indemnisations seront versés fin 2021
dernier délai et au delà des biens
impacté à court terme le gouvernement et
vous pouvez me faire confiance entend
trouver une solution globale et pérenne
pour la gestion du recul du trait de
côte comme cela a été présenté lors du
conseil de défense écologique du 12
février 2011 devant merci mais aussi
madame le ministre
la parole est à monsieur philippe la
tombe merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
justice et garde des sceaux monsieur le
ministre la législation européenne est
particulièrement soucieuse du droit de
chacun au respect de sa vie privée et à
la protection de ses données
personnelles
ainsi en juillet dernier la cour de
justice de l'union européenne a invalidé
le privacy shield un accord qui autorise
le transfert de données personnelles
européenne vers les états unis
il ya quelques jours la cour a également
considéré que les fournisseurs de
services de communications électroniques
ne peuvent se voir imposer une
conservation généralisée et
indifférenciée des données relatives au
trafic et à la localisation sans que le
comportement des personnes concernées
justifient une telle collecte au regard
de l'objectif poursuivi
elle rappelle ainsi le principe
incontournable du respect de la vie
privée un fondement des sociétés
modernes démocratique
cela signifie monsieur le ministre que
notre législation sur ce point et les
procédures qui en découlent ne sont pas
en règle avec le droit européen les
députés du groupe démocrate
très soucieux du respect de la vie
privée n'en n'ont pas moins constaté
l'ampleur de l'inquiétude des enquêteurs
et des magistrats
la collecte de ces données en effet jugé
crucial tant pour les investigations que
pour les procès qui s'en suivent ainsi
une vraie incertitude pèse sur les
procédures pénales en cours dont les
éléments de preuve ont été obtenues par
une conservation de données contraire au
droit européen
droit national va devoir rapidement
s'adapter afin de tenir compte de cette
interdiction et prévoir les exceptions à
ce principe posé par la cour de justice
dans le cadre des menaces graves et
persistantes pour la sécurité nationale
c'est pourquoi devant une telle
situation qui n'avait pas été anticipé
en dépit des alertes de notre groupe sur
cette potentielle invalidation pouvez
vous monsieur le ministre nous indiquer
comment vous entendez mettre notre droit
en conformité avec le droit de l'union
européenne et selon quel calendrier
je remercie merci la parole de monsieur
eric dupond-moretti garde des sceaux
monsieur résidents mais là messieurs les
députés monsieur le député la tombe
lorsque nous avons à plusieurs reprises
organisé des réunions ayant pour thème
la sécurité sous l'autorité du premier
ministre du président de la république
avec le ministre de l'intérieur
contrairement très ce que vous dites
pardon nous avions anticipé la
jurisprudence qualifié appelez vous le
savez de tele2 et la cour la grande
chambre de la cour de justice de l'union
vient de confirmer cette jurisprudence
mais vous le savez également cet arrêt
qui est particulièrement touffus prévoit
un certain nombre d'exceptions notamment
en matière de protection de la sécurité
intérieure et de lutte contre la grande
criminalité
alors nous allons bien sûr continuer de
travailler sur cette question en faisant
évidemment très attention à d'une part
la protection des libertés individuelles
et des données bien sûr et en même temps
il faut permettre absolument obstinément
que la sécurité et que d'autres sécurité
soit assurée je veux vous rassurer
et je vous prie de me croire lorsque je
vous affirme qu'avec le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avons déjà engagé un
véritable travail auquel naturellement
le parlement sera légitimement associés
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole était madame marine brunier
merci monsieur le président mon cher
collègue
ce n'est pas la député de la nation qui
s'expriment devant vous mais l'une des
représentantes de l'ancien comté de nice
désormais métropole nice côte d'azur
les niçois forment un peuple de
montagnards avec les pieds dans la
méditerranée et la tête dans les cimes
du mercantour
nous sommes tous de la vésubie de la
roya ou de la tinée c'est notre identité
avant tout je souhaite remercier votre
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre ainsi que le président de la
république pour être venu dans notre
territoire et pour toutes les annonces
qui ont suivi vous avez pu mesurer
l'élan incroyable de solidarité démarre
alpin pendant plus d'une semaine
j'ai conduit le convoi
d'approvisionnement pour les habitants
de la vésubie aux côtés des agents de la
métropole et des bénévoles qui ont fait
un travail formidable
merci également aux gendarmes aux
pompiers aux agents de force 06 et aux
bénévoles qui font preuve d'un
dévouement sans pareil avec christian
estrosi le président de la métropole
nice côte d'azur avec notre collègue
eric ciotti nous sommes totalement
mobilisés sur la reconstruction de nos
vallées aux côtés des maires des
communes sinistrées
mais après l'attentât de nice est en
pleine crise sanitaire
nous n'imaginions pas être frappé encore
si durement
nous aurons besoin d'un état fort pour
nous accompagner dans cette
reconstruction
le chemin sera très long les 110
millions d'euros a annoncé le soulage
mais ne peuvent être qu'une première
étape vers un engagement encore plus
massifs l'eau l'assainissement les
routes les ponts les réseaux les
services publics les maisons tout est à
reconstruire
nous aurons besoin de mesures fortes
pour accompagner les particuliers et
professionnels en les exonérant les
charges et des impôts
nous aurons besoin que vous acceptiez de
déroger à la loi montagne pour permettre
à ceux qui n'ont plus rien de pouvoir
reconstruire en ouvrant des bulles
d'urbanisation nous aurons besoin que
vous soyez à nos côtés pour les
discussions avec les assurances pour les
sinistrés
monsieur le premier ministre la france
est si belle de ces territoires ruraux
aidez nous à les sauver je vous remercie
si mon but est la parole de monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée permettez moi de vous
répondre en tant que député la nation en
soulignant en effet la grande solidarité
nationale et premier ministre par sa
venue
l'ong l écoute des habitants accompagné
de vous-même de monsieur députés se ti
du maire pessiot estrosi du président
monsieur ginésy de tous les
parlementaires des alpes-maritimes se
dombreval adam ardisson qui ont pendant
les visites du premier ministre la
visite du président de la république
apporter un soutien et avec barbara
pompidou nous travaillons pour le
ministère de l'intérieur à l'urgence et
pour le ministre la transition
écologique à la reconstruction et des
questions se posent également qui relève
sans doute du ministère de l'action et
des comptes publics
le colis vie du soft pour accompagner
permettez moi au moment où demain les
élus accompagneront sans doute madame la
ministre déléguée à la citoyenneté
je veux dire jeudi matin pardon pour
l'enterrement de ce pompier pour qui je
veux avoir un mot particulier
en attendant peut-être de découvrir le
deuxième les deux victimes 17 ans
pompier en saluant comme vous l'avez
fait les gendarmes les agents de l'état
les agents des collectivités locales et
notamment ceux du conseil départemental
de la métropole dressé devant vous
monsieur le président le bilan humain
est un peu malheureusement matériel va
ce que vous l'avez très bien dit
beaucoup sera encore à évaluer la
solidarité nationale aura à s'exprimer
présent n'a plus qu'à 10 de cette
terrible tempête
c' est décédé nous n'oublions pas le
décès n'est d'ailleurs en bretagne
puisque la tempête est aussi passé par
la bretagne 12 disparus 800 sauvetage et
mise en sécurité réalisé 590 cet
engagement de sécurité civile 952
d'ailleurs au plus fort nous avons eu
huit hélicoptères dont 13 plus fort qui
tourne encore dans le votre département
des alpes-maritimes 18 équipes
cynophiles 55 communes reconnues comme
catastrophe naturelle à la demande du
premier ministre
trois jours après les événements 1562
bâtiment gendotti diagnostiqué par
l'émission bâtimentaire madame la
ministre
59 bâtiment classé noir ou totalement
détruits 159 bâtiment classé rouge avec
un arrêté de mise en péril
oui vous avez
on se sera plus de 100 millions d'euros
qu'il faudra pour le département pour se
relever merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame célia de lavergne
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame la ministre en
charge de la cohésion des territoires
à la grande satisfaction de tous les
parlementaires de ces bancs vous avez
dit haut et fort votre attachement votre
soutien à tous nos territoires nous le
disons aussi à nos territoires ruraux
qui ont beau depuis trop longtemps
souffert de la migration des populations
vers les centres urbains souffert de la
disparition du recul des services
publics et souvent de service public
privé est essentielle à la vie de nos
concitoyens créant un sentiment
d'abandon et de déclassement
nous ne laissons plus faire cela nous ne
laisserons plus faire cela avant tout
parce que les français réhabi tno
campagne et que le coc vide accélère ce
processus
ensuite parce que vous et nous depuis
menon ensemble une politique
volontariste en faveur de rades de la
ruralité par la revitalisation des
centres urbains par le désenclavement de
nos territoires avec le financement de
petites lignes de routes secondaires de
la fibre de la 4g par la création par le
soutien aux collectivités territoriales
rural par la création de maisons france
service pour rapprocher en proximité et
avec un visage humain
le service public pour les habitants des
territoires ruraux toutes ces mesures
qui font de la gendarmerie
porté par un secrétariat d'état à la
ruralité un élément essentiel de notre
politique mais des inquiétudes
persistent des inquiétudes sur le
dispositif de zone de revitalisation
rurale qui aujourd'hui doit prendre fin
d'ici la fin de l'année
un dispositif d'exonérations fiscales et
sociales qui permet de créer de l'emploi
de la valeur de l'activité dans nos
territoires
que va-t-il advenir de ce dispositif des
inquiétudes concernant le plan de
relance il faut aller vite pour financer
nos projets mais qui dit vite dit avoir
l'ingénierie technique dit la prime aux
sortants comment aider des territoires
fragiles comme nos territoires ruraux a
bénéficié de manière équitable au plan
de relance
merci merci
collègues la parole est à madame
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée célia de la vergne comme vous le
soulignez le dispositif des zones de
revitalisation rurale arrive à échéance
le 31 décembre prochain avec joël giraud
secrétaire d'état la ruralité
nous savons l'inquiétude que l'avenir de
ce dispositif suscite auprès des élus
locaux et aussi des professionnels
bénéficiaires de cette de ce zonage
particulièrement je dirais en cette
période de crise nous savons aussi que
notre géographie prioritaire dont le
coût a été évalué à environ 650 millions
mérite d'être réformé pour mieux
soutenir les territoires qui en ont le
plus besoin des rapports parlementaires
ont d'ailleurs souligné son caractère un
peu complexe et insuffisamment cible et
ce pendant la période de crise que nous
vivons a conduit le premier ministre à
penser qu'il fallait stabiliser les
outils existants comme nous l'avons
annoncé dès la présentation du plf 2021
nous déposerons donc un amendement
prolongeant les zrr de deux ans jusqu'au
mois de décembre 2022
vous m'interrogez par ailleurs sur le
plan de relance et sur les territoires
ruraux
je voudrais vous assurer que le premier
ministre met tout en oeuvre pour que les
100 milliards de la relance descendent
le plus efficacement possible sur les
territoires et sachez que je partage
votre souci sur les appels à projets qui
pourraient complexe qui pourrait
éloigner les territoires ruraux de cette
réponse
eh bien il faut vous dire que nous
allons des concentrés au niveau des
territoires des prêts faits à la main
des préfets de région et de département
des sommes importantes et notre souci
bien évidemment c'est que le plan de
relance répondent
aux projets des collectivités
territoriales dans les territoires merci
madame la ministre
la séance des questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue